happy friday ladies and gentlemen we do
the show obviously at night so for those
listening tomorrow it's friday and i'm
going to do intros really quick because
i'm going to jump right into the story
my friends we're under attack someone is
trying to sabotage the gorilla
and i will not stand for it so let me
just quickly announce we got luke kowski
hanging out
what
[Laughter]
uh is that all you're going to say you
can see senior oh okay okay
we got ian he's chilling hola yeah it's
just us tonight and lydia press the
button yeah i'm over here in the corner
yeah because uh uh
i'm outraged my friends we're gonna
we're gonna jump straight into this one
because this one is more personal and we
got a lot of news we got a lot of news
you know
joe biden is the the marjorie taylor
green filed impeachment against them
we'll talk about this stuff we'll talk
about a lot of stuff
we got the q anon shaman is mad at trump
he wanted a pardon
cove mandatory vaccines for all
employees of united trust me we've got
news
but this time it's personal my friends
if you go to timcast.com
okay we have a new website set up where
you can become a member
and help support the show and we're
trying really hard to
make that a bigger part of the show for
several reasons it allows us
to speak freely without fear of getting
banned from youtube because our own
website
and it helps support us outside of these
ridiculous ad sales and rules and all
that stuff now
please go there become everyone support
the show but i bring this up because we
also have an
area called shop and when you go to shop
you can purchase this ever so lovely i
am a gorilla t-shirt trust me this is
part of the story and you're going to
want to hear this
the gorilla t-shirt is a joke when alex
jones is on the show
he kept saying i am a gorilla kill
yourself well we didn't like that why
well because the it's based on this book
called ishmael where this like spirit
was in a spirit gorilla uh this guy was
like seeking the meaning of life he
finds this gorilla who has telepathic
powers
and talks to him telepathically okay
like guerrilla grodd from dc i guess i
don't know
he's a villain he's basically what
telling people that they're like a virus
well yeah he's explaining that humans
have kind of ended up becoming too
too much of takers in the world and
we're kind of destroying the planet now
instead of how we're supposed to live
symbiotically with it okay okay
so ian ended up saying i am a gorilla
love yourself and so we thought that was
funny people in the chat kept saying i'm
a girl and posting gorilla emojis
and i liked the idea of focusing on
getting back to nature you know being
responsible for yourself
because you know when we had jack murphy
here i mentioned what ishmael is kind of
about
and when i said it's you know get back
to nature and you know get in the
wilderness maybe chop some lumber jack's
like that sounds pretty good you know
what i mean
and so i'm like let's make a positive
thing i don't do political shirts
luke does political shirts look look at
the shirt he's wearing right now well
well
i get my shirt censored but that's a
whole nother story though we're going to
give it a little bit
but luke's got political shirts it's or
it's orwell saying boy did i call it or
what
it's a great shirt it's a great as well
the tim guest irl shirts
are not political and on purpose we have
one where it says silence accelerates
victory it's the old slogan from the u.s
office of censorship it's about as
political as we get
and ends the pyramid you know with the
great with the awesome eye being toppled
over
that was before irl right yes that was
something i made a while ago
as just like it's i thought it was cool
it's like the censorship being knocked
over we'll win
that's about as political as we get
because we have a cat we've got me with
a pipe with bubbles coming out
and shirts with beanies on them that's
right you buy a shirt got a beanie on it
so when we made the i am a gorilla shirt
i put tim cast irl on it and it's meant
to just to be
a silly thing for the fans people listen
to the show no strong message
i'm about to show you an image most of
you probably have already seen me tweet
about it
because when i saw this i was just like
i face-palmed i'll admit
you know i'm i'm a pretty chill person
so i was laughing but i was like
still kind of worried at this someone
ordered this shirt one of the first
shirts to go out and this is what
happened
ladies and gentlemen i give you the
sabotage of the i am a gorilla shirt i
am offended
the i am a guerrilla meme was supposed
to be fun and silly and family friendly
and it is just a drawing of a silly
cartoon gorilla sitting there like yeah
i'm a gorilla it doesn't mean anything
well here's the image i got
on the left you can see the original
artwork on the right you can see what
was delivered
to someone who ordered the shirt for
those that are listening i said yo
teespring
you want to tell me why our cartoon
gorilla shirt became an effing blackface
drawing
how was this an accident his hands were
printed white and his face was darkened
this is the crazy thing about it a lot
of people have suggested
that this was some kind of printing
error it wasn't
now the first thing i want to say i've
talked with teespring and they're
working on solving
figuring out what happened and it is
definitely on their end
but not through their main company what
they told me is they
they believe this came from a third
party that they outsourced to
and uh look i respect teespring i like
them i've sold shirts with them for a
long time
and i have no issues with them so i
respect they called me and they were
really apologetic and they were like we
really want to get to the bottom of this
we don't like being called racists and i
was like i don't i don't want people
walking around with tim cast irl
branding
and this ridiculous image let me explain
something this is a picture of
of what looks like some it looks like a
minstrel costume
because the fists were changed to be
white the face
is blackened but you can see the where
the black on the faces it doesn't reach
all the way to the end of the face
kind of like black face so some people
said it was a printing error
i don't know how that would be a
printing error because you can see that
there are certain colors that appear in
certain areas and on other areas
how did they accidentally make the fists
white and accidentally then make the
face
darker not only that the color of shirt
is gray
i don't off we don't offer that in the
teespring store it seems like
somebody purposefully altered the image
and printed it on a shirt
maybe i don't know what happened maybe
someone thought it was a joke
and they printed it out for their
friends and then it accidentally got
shipped out or maybe someone
intentionally wanted
people to be walking around with a shirt
that says tim cast irl on it
and depicts what looks like blackface
saying i'm a gorilla
so look i ain't all that mad okay we all
we all kind of laughed and we're like
what are you gonna do about it
you know it's ridiculous but the the the
indignation you hear is because i think
someone did it on purpose
and i don't think they did it because it
was fun or funny i think they did it
because it would seriously hurt us
so when i saw this image get sent out my
initial reaction was
if this person didn't tell me and i
didn't know
and they didn't think of it how long
would it take until media matters or
some leftist organization
started saying that tim poole sells
black face shirts or whatever
it would probably take 10 seconds so i
immediately tweeted no none of that
you're not doing that on me
not me so then then because of that
some people started photoshopping it and
trying to sell it on other stores
because you can't get any more so
i will tell you this uh i talked to
teespring
and they said it's not going to happen
again and i was like cool
but a lot of people may have ordered it
and it may have already been sent out
so there may be 1 000 of these shirts
circulating around with altered art and
i had no idea
maybe they didn't all come from the same
printing facility but uh
look i'm trying to be nice to teespring
you know um
i understand their business i understand
they're scared of the accusations and
cancel culture and all that stuff as
well
but let me let me just you know make a
few more points and then we'll point
out what they've done with luke's shirts
and that suggests that
well i don't want to i don't want to
abandon you know teespring over what a
rogue employee may have done
but i i take issue with that and i
definitely think there's quality control
issues
because a few questions let's say it was
an accident let's say it was a mistake
how did someone look at that and say
looks like the design the person ordered
let's send it to him
they didn't even stop and say yeah
that's definitely not the art it's
supposed to be
they sent out a clearly defective shirt
but come on
the darkened face and the white hands
this was done
on purpose in my opinion so
look i try to be careful and i can
understand the people who run teespring
are probably freaking out
and i feel bad for them i do because
they didn't do this somebody somebody
did somebody at the company or or
through the company did somehow
and so i just tried to be i tried to be
nice and proud to give people the
benefit of the doubt but i think moving
forward
for at least the timcast.com store and
for members
we'll probably print our own shirts and
and sell them manually
because then we can guarantee this
doesn't happen
now that being said i'm sure there are a
lot of people who actually really want
one of these now because misprints end
up becoming valuable or popular
and look all that matters to me is i
said
i don't condone what the person did with
this art and i'm not gonna you know risk
me getting cancelled by someone trying
to accuse me of doing something if you
find it funny you know so be it whatever
they're sold
and a lot of people are probably gonna
get them um i don't think you can get
them now if you tried to order but if
you just want the regular one which was
supposed to just be silly
and a lot of people are like it's a dumb
shirt what's the point i'm like that
it's not supposed to be
anything special it's just you watch the
show you like it i'm a gorilla have fun
now luke has his own encounters because
they just took down your shirts like the
other day didn't they well they took
down ten shirts
and uh like yesterday right yesterday
the shirt i was wearing
they took down after the broadcast and
i'm like wait what i mean
the shirt that i was wearing the one
that said that had the npc saying
don't spread fake news because uh the
mainstream media hates competition and
had all the mainstream media
they took that one down and i'm like hey
what's going on here i have a puppy to
feed i'm finally back on my feet
i'm finally doing well i don't work for
anyone i volunteer
youtube took away my my demonetization
and now
out of everything here come these
alleged snitches or or and now they're
taking away
the main kind of income that i have and
i'm like wait what's going on here i
reached out to them
yeah the shirt you were wearing said
don't distribute fake news the
mainstream media will do it for you
yeah why why would they take that down
why would they remove that exactly and
they took down a lot of other stuff and
they haven't been honest
but you know being you know polish being
very hard-headed and stubborn
i'm still going to keep moving forward
and even if i have to draw these shirts
myself and ship them out to the people i
still
will do that because uh a lot of people
have been telling me i love these shirts
they help spread the conversation i love
talking to random people people stop me
in the middle of the streets to talk
about
you know the the the information the
larger kind of message that you're
getting out there
so uh i mean i'm i'm very happy that i
bought the best political shirts.com
that specific domain because now
i'm just going to use it and whatever
shirts they took down
i you know i'm i'm talking to them
hopefully they will bring it back but if
they don't
i'm still looking for third parties i'm
going to find a third party to work with
and then all the shirts that were ever
banned there was i i found out yesterday
there was 10
10 products banned 10. i didn't even
know about this
uh the emails were going to the span box
and uh
i was wondering i was like my store just
looks kind of skinny there so there's
i'm very dissatisfied there's a lot of
services like teespring
and look they they just texted me and
they said
you know we're so sorry about this we're
going to work on it we're going to
figure out the problem was and follow up
with you and i respect it i do i try to
be nice
and um i'm i'm sure there's probably a
lot of people that are laughing at how
egregious
this was and knowing that it's not
intended to actually
you know insult anybody or actually be
racist i'm sure a lot of people would
like to have that shirt
now that being said teespring like i
said they're not going to allow they're
not going to allow any any more of these
to go out and they're going to monitor
them
but considering some of the censorship
we've seen
from teespring i'll keep using them
because they're integrated with youtube
they actually are pretty good service i
know a lot of people aren't the biggest
fans of their shirts but luke mentioned
that these shirts
actually have been you know pretty good
for a long time like they last a while
but that being said we're going to have
to take the the reigns into our own
hands
if luke can't criticize the mainstream
media like come on
you can't criticize the problem maybe
it's that you had their logos on those
well they also took down
my logo so i had i had merchandise with
my own original we are change
logos on there and they took that one
down as well
that's a good point i respect that yeah
i think that might be it but it but
satire and fair use is allowed yeah you
can drink a pepsi
on this show and get ad revenue for it
but luke was making fun of them yeah
as long as it's satirical it it's
allowed as long as
it's it's creative commons it's it's it
was a new creation clearly mocking the
brand and in no way sought to
monetize off of those companies brands
if i took the cnn logo and was just
selling the cnn logo then yes you can
make that argument i
stole their intellectual property but
not when you have you know 25
other media organizations can i put like
sell a shirt that says nintendo with
like i'm pouring a cup of water on it
yes you can
really yup because you've edited it
you've changed it yes so
the the question of copyright
infringement is are you infringing on
their market
so uh famous story with sargon of akkad
carl benjamin
low to cedars podcast i always give a
shout out to carl and
uh he he took a video on youtube from a
left wing
you know commentator and then he took
two cuts of it just straight like
cut and cut and then titled it i think
it was sjw levels of awareness
she sued him saying oh you just stole my
content and a bunch of people were like
yeah dude carl like
you did you're gonna lose and he's like
no i'm not i'm right it's fair use he
won not only did he win
he won fees as well she had to pay him
on top
because you're allowed to criticize
other people
and produce a new product and monetize
it if it's in the in the process of
criticizing
mocking satirizing the big question when
it comes to the court is
are you infringing on their market so
like luke said if you just sell shirts
that say cnn
then you're taking money away from cnn
who sells the same shirts
but if it says cnn and then sucks under
it cnn doesn't sell those shirts and
cnn's fans wouldn't buy them anyway
yeah so you can do that yeah we made a
cnn logo that transformed into a toilet
uh and i think they took
that that that one down that one down as
well and i'm like
what's going on here and it's not just
uh you know
copyright it's also our logos our own
independent arts they took down a whole
bunch of other stuff
claimed it was copyright but there was
no possible way in the world
that that could be true and then we
countered them on it and this happened a
couple
months ago and they still never
responded to me so i'm taking this very
seriously i'm very happy i have this new
domain name because i'm going to be
using it i'm going to make my own store
uh you know maybe i'll use them maybe on
that we'll see if you guys respond to me
but
but just keep checking in on the best
political shirts.com because if you want
that shirt that i had on yesterday
i'm working to make sure you have it one
way or another even if i don't get any
profit
a lot of people want that shirt i'm
gonna make sure you guys have it i got
an idea
for the i am a gorilla shirt we'll just
make one where he's holding a rainbow
flag
that's it okay so he's got his face
let's just put a rainbow flag there and
like hey we're cool
like a rainbow chinese finger trap he's
like um
teespring takes like 85 right no like
like
50 or so that's not bad because they do
98 of the labor
right they take the order they ship it
out they make it and all that stuff we
were talking last night while we were
on twitch adam and i about uh doing
t-shirts here
because we i think this conversation
came up but it the consensus was it's
just a lot of work
shift especially the shipping yeah but
so if we do the limited
edition stuff like the tin foil hat
version i'm going to get those made by a
local small business
and then we're going to physically have
them and we can sign them and then do a
limited run members only
and then i think for the shop we have on
timecast.com i might just have to
like maintain full control over this you
know look i i
misprints are fun like we we play magic
yeah you know for those that aren't
familiar and like card games like magic
the gathering you get a miscut or a
misprint they can be worth way more
money
this is probably the craziest thing to
like look that's why i think it's on
purpose the fact that there
they say oh you know maybe it was a
mistake i'm like come on there's too
many things that had to go wrong for
this to be a mistake
that's why people need
the hands were accidentally made white
instead of black and the face was
darkened
to play devil's advocate maybe because
the shirt was a different color
the ink didn't print right on it but the
hands are white
instead of black that doesn't make sense
it's like there's no ink where the hands
are
no there is there is ink it's white ink
yeah yeah it's wild it's light
and this is like a tiny shirt right no
no it's a gray shirt great
it's the gray speckled whatever it's
called it's called heather
so what i noticed about this was that
the mouth was a different shape so i
really no i don't think so i think
you're wrong tim thinks i'm wrong
yeah you're wrong it's the same it's the
same somebody else went in there and
they're like i'm going to change this
why would they change the
vector of the mouth yeah they don't even
have the vector image they have a png
why do they make it look like blackface
so changing colors is easy
changing vectorized shapes is not they
whitened a lot of black spots but not
the outline of the guy
it stayed black i i saw how it was
designed so the designer sent me an
image of all the layers and like broke
it down and there is no way that could
have been an accident so the ears are
white why are the ears wet right
yeah you know the nose is white too is
that a black throwback
someone said maybe it was inverted
accidentally that's kind of what it
looks like but look at his forearms the
forearms are the same colors
um who did the printing did they tell
you they're third party
they just so at first they told me that
it was actually a totally different
company that was ripping it off
and they sent me a link and i looked at
it and at first i was like oh whoa is
that what happened
but the person who bought the shirt is
the designer
and so i just asked the designer did you
buy the shirt yes here's the receipt
do you have the packaging yes here's the
packaging okay well that's shady that
they told you
it was someone else i think no i think
they may have thought that was the case
what actually happened was when i
tweeted about it
someone took a photo like photoshopped
it out and then made a version
but the font they used was different and
so i told them immediately i was like
look
i was like i got the package i got the
receipt the font is different
and they were like well can you verify
and i was like i'm not going to accuse
one of people who contracts the designs
for me of lying to me
like we've gotten art from them before
it's been fantastic we've
like this is i thought it was a great
shirt yeah there's no way
when we when when i don't even sell that
color of shirt on my teespring store
and so they were like you know we're
looking at we have a task force on this
they were freaking out they said like
the whole country woke up you know like
everybody's
i tweeted like dude this is not on me
i'm i'm not taking heat for this one
that's on you man
cancel culture is going crazy right now
and i'll tell you i'm maybe i'm a little
paranoid
but they're looking for any and every
reason to ban people i think you did
a really good thing by tweeting it out
immediately as soon as i saw it yeah
because they're looking for reasons to
ban people we already had media matters
claim that we were pushing fake news in
some video because jack murphy
said that donald trump said something
he's like donald trump was talking about
this then this
and so they were like they're pushing
lies and then they they lied media
matter said the ads have been roofed
they weren't
but you know what happens is they put i
asked them for a retraction twice and
they've ignored me
what happens is media matters will put
out a story saying these channels broke
the rules
and then they'll start sharing that
article to try and get in wikipedia
trying to get other outlets to write
about it tim poole who's known for
breaking the rules blah blah
when it never happened and so now i have
to closely monitor this stuff
because if we actually sustain damages
these lies become pervasive what's this
media matters thing i haven't heard of
it before they wrote an article claiming
that
on one of our videos one of our segments
jack murphy said that donald trump was
speaking and gave examples of voter
fraud
like out of state voters and things like
that giving an example of what voter
fraud is is not
us asserting that widespread voter fraud
caused anything to happen and so they
claimed we were pushing lies
they also referenced an incoherent super
chat that i read that you couldn't
really understand
and then said because of it youtube took
our ads away
that's not oh wow true who runs media
matters it's a bunch of activists
but what happens is they create that
narrative and then other leftists who
read that will be like oh tim
they said the ads were removed on the
video and they said oh oh the ads got
removed tim pools
was penalized by youtube and they'll try
and create the narrative that youtube is
punishing no youtube did not
the podcast was fully monetized and as
of right now
the video is fully monetized so i don't
know how did they know that
well i think someone at youtube probably
told them that and
what whatever whatever their point is i
asked them to retract it and they didn't
can you toss me some of that collagen
this is not collagen that's the mct yeah
i'm gonna put in my coffee
do it thanks free free free sideways
we're not plugging these guys tonight
but i'm putting some nct oil in my
coffee
well because we actually just eat the
stuff because it's amazing yeah anyway
look
that the point is when it comes to this
i am a gorilla thing
i don't know who did it or why i don't i
don't care
i'm not i'm not taking heat for somebody
walking around wearing that shirt and
then them being like oh look at the
shirts he's selling
all it takes is like one dummy to wear
at one really bad rally with a really
bad sign
and you're you know labeled with it so
so we've seen a kind of transition and a
trend
online that's really worrying where you
have to be responsible for every comment
you have to be responsible for every
viewer you have to be responsible for
people who consume your content now
which is absolutely insane and it's
impossible and it's selectively enforced
because they could say look who's
watching your channels this is why you
don't have a discourse i don't have a
discourse because
people can support discord because
people could just go on there and they
could
false flag it with a whole bunch of
crazy messages and say
look this is this is your people look
what your people and i remember a couple
years ago them trying to do this
on me and it backfired with just
salacious
insane text of individuals blaming one
race of people and i'm like wait wait
this doesn't represent me i'll tell you
something funny i had a discord for a
while and i got rid of it because we
kept getting raided
you know people would come in and try
and break the rules you agree to the
rules and they would come in and they
would post insane garbage
and i'm like dude i'm not dealing with
this the moderators couldn't deal with
it but what happened was this left-wing
group
i actually know one of the founders it's
called unicorn riot had archived the
entire discord
and took a segment of me talking
where i was criticizing vox.com for
publishing white nationalist
propaganda and they cut out the parts
where i was saying
how could vox say these things is
ridiculous fox's being so racist
and then just took the parts where i
literally quoted the vox article to
criticize it and claimed i said it
yeah what these people like to unicorn
riot yeah
yep and i know one of the founders and
i've known for a long time why did they
do that because these people
are they're they're zealots they're
they're authoritarians and they believe
that they're morally justified in evil
because they're the end results for them
is good wow so they took
me literally saying hey guys look at vox
promoting white nationalism these people
are disgusting
and then clipped at my criticism and
tried to make it seem like i was the one
so what happened was vox.com had a doc
a psychologist a doctor write an article
where he
literally claimed that uh vox.com
claimed
in an op-ed from a from a psychologist
that jewish people
according to vox inherent inherit
genetically and is what vox said
their materialism and i said that's
insane oh that that seems insane you see
how i had to break it up to avoid the
out of context pulling that's what
they'll do
and don't don't worry they'll still chop
it up so i'm like i think that inherits
a weird word because you inherit money
from well inherent is the generic
genetic inheritance
so i said here's what the doctor said oh
my god that is insane
and they took out all of my critique and
just took the quote from the doctor and
claimed the quote from the doctor was
from me
i'm not a phd researcher who writes for
fox sorry guys
but they knew my name was next to it
they posted a screenshot look what tim
poole said and it works
yeah it's crazy that we're living in a
world where the mainstream media is
literally paying people to watch
everything we say and it's at a point
where they can't
even critique us so they invent things
to critique us on
i remember people being like look at
your followers look at what your
followers are saying look what the
comment section of your youtube channel
you're saying and i'm like i'm
responsible for that now they're like
yes you are a hundred percent literally
you look
like you have something to say so luke
do you think this is maybe because
they're making these things
publishers they're not platforms anymore
you are
responsible for everything that happens
there like do you think that's part of
it
well that's another you know argument
about section what is it 2 30
that everyone's talking about but but
before we even go there we have to
understand these are institutions the
mainstream media that told us that there
was weapons of mass destruction
that told us that bankers deserve
bailouts in 2008
that told us the air was safe to breathe
on 9 11. they have
zero to little accountability at
all for their grotesque lies that lead
to tremendous human suffering
but yet we have to be screwed
criticized for for comments on our youth
it's obvious it's obvious dude
when uh what was the what did the
babylon be say that they put out a joke
so i don't know if you guys heard the
story that the national guard was forced
to sleep in a parking garage with no
bathroom
with one bathroom like two stalls with
five thousand soldiers five
thousand soldiers one one power outlet
in a parking lot yes
and so the babylon b set joe biden asks
national guard to be patient
until he can send them to iraq while
they sleep in parking garage until he
can send him to a rock
so the the reason i bring that up is
there's a reason why they'll do
everything in their power to get us
taken down
now if we play by the rules and we we
don't violate community standards
whatever it's really difficult
sometimes they take down channels
arbitrarily hoping they can get away
with it
and then when there's a back a backlash
they put it back up the mainstream media
and the establishment elites want to be
able to
yell that we need war and lie about
weapons of mass destruction to get us
into war
and they don't like it when independent
media challenges that narrative or
chemical weapons attacks
in syria which after further
investigation was found out to be
absolutely lied about by the
establishment and the mainstream media
and all of course these neoconservatives
and the state department and department
of defense
but you but you can even go back to the
gulf of tonkin incident
what got us involved in vietnam widely
believed i got you know
still be careful it was just it never
happened they claimed the u.s was
attacked it wasn't they needed pretext
for getting us involved in vietnam
so when we can pull up the actual
research and i'm not talking about
conspiracy theories
i'm talking about you just google search
the gulf of tonkin and said read read
wikipedia wikipedia says all this
it's easier when the new york times can
say their weapons of mass destruction it
is harder when there are channels like
this going
can you prove it yeah before you commit
our troops to death can you prove it
even then hold on i just want to make a
point before going right to you ian
there was even whistleblowers there was
people within our government
during that entire phase screaming like
hey
there there is no evidence at all that
there's weapons of mass destruction
there was voices i remember being
at one of the largest demonstrations
ever in american history in washington
dc
hearing from whistleblowers within our
government warning us that this was a
lie
they were all ignored by the mainstream
media the internet was still coming up
that's how i heard of it
that's why there was a large
demonstration and and yet still we went
forward with this it's
ridiculous sorry ian go ahead gulf of
tonkin was a conspiracy
by the government they conspired to
produce this fallacious
uh thing so there there are government
conspiracies i mean that is
the gulf they admitted yes we conspired
it didn't actually happen
i don't think they admitted i think it
was uh journalists
uh daniel ellsberg did he come out in
the pentagon papers was it revealed
it may have been actually i'm not
entirely sure it was the uss maddox
incident
an international confrontation that led
to the in uh
direct engagement into vietnam it
involved both a proven confrontation on
august 2nd
and an unlikely confrontation on august
4th
so that's why i try to be careful
because you know even you go to
wikipedia but
we were told over and over and over
again what you know that
we had been attacked and we had to we
had to go in and now you know decades
later
they say it we don't even know if it
happened at all
so what do they specifically say there
were no u.s casualties it was originally
claimed by the nsa
that a second gulf of tonkin incident
occurred on august 4th
as another sea battle but instead
evidence was found of tonkin ghosts
false radar images
and not actual north vietnamese torpedo
boats in the 2003 documentary the fog of
war the former united states secretary
of defense robert s mcnamara admitted
that the august 2nd uss maddox attack
happened with no defense department
response
but the august 4th the gulf of tonkin
attack never happened
the nsa claimed it did and then they
admitted in 2003
what was a former former guy wasn't he
he said he was out of the military
yeah robert mcnamara was was he the uh
who who
yeah yeah what did he what he did
something else his name's familiar
sometimes i wish i was 80 years old
well yeah in 2003 yeah it never happened
never happened dude they conspired
government conspiracy and we have to
understand what led to that what were
the larger consequences
let me just still be reasonable i guess
or they're just
really bad at what they do they're wrong
that's always a possibility it is
and and you know this hanlon's razor
never attribute to malice that which
would but
they explained through lyndon johnson
really wanted us in the vietnam
a lot of people wanted us because they
were afraid of the russia and his secret
war in cambodia
and laos i mean when you look at the
atrocities that were committed in our
name
because of that single incident
especially in vietnam
the millions of people affected the
millions of people still affected by
agent orange and the chemical warfare
that was
launched on the vietnamese people on
innocent bystanders wholly
these are the american young men who
were drafted to go and fight in that and
then spent lives with with injuries
with you know permanent disabilities and
all of that stuff coming back
watching their friends die that was that
was some sick stuff that we got
and it's like we barely hear some of
what those
guys have gone through like to be
overrun to be in a in a
hole at night in the middle of the night
waking up every two hours
and it you got to listen to vietnam
veterans
talk about their yeah it's for what to
stop by the communism in vietnam maybe
or maybe it was a financial thing it was
kissinger's limited war they we didn't
want war with russia we didn't want to
bomb moscow so we were going to fight
him in vietnam
those are little proxy wars those proxy
wars are still continuing
they were supposedly based on ideologies
communism versus capitalism in reality
it was empires vying for power
it's exactly what's happening right now
in syria in yemen
what happened in libya what happened in
iraq what happened in afghanistan
all of that are powers vying for more
power
vying for geopolitical hegemony and
control
of not only trade routes but important
national resources
which of course they're doing anything
and everything for including sacrificing
the lives of
your sons of your daughters of your
children for profit
let's let's let's let's roll with this
do you know you guys know the berlin
wall is
yeah yeah so we'll talk about the cold
war and the us versus russia and vietnam
but
you guys listening to this you're gonna
love it do you know what the what it was
what it was called in east germany
it was called the anti-fascist rampart
how nice the anti-fascist
protection rampart the berlin wall
i saw a photo someone posted on twitter
of people carrying just two bags running
full speed
because uh that was when they announced
they're going to be erecting the berlin
wall
and people ran desperately to get to
east germany
because i'm sorry west germany not to
east germany to west germany because
they realized what was about to happen
and then someone posted a photo of the
first person that died at the
anti-fascist protection rampart it's
really funny about the
anti-fascist protection rampart is that
people
they weren't protecting anybody that the
wall wasn't protecting east germany
it was keeping the people in like a
prison and the first person to die was
trying to escape
i read one story about a doodle i took a
hot air balloon over it oh wow
people were so desperate to get out of
that place look i can understand
why the us was so adamant about fighting
russia i'm sorry the soviet union on so
many fronts
because you hear stories like this but i
want to make sure we remind everybody
just read about this gdr authorities
officially refer to the berlin wall as
the anti-fascist protection rampart
in german the anti-fascist
wall brilliant so the antifa rampart
and so now you have people in this
country going around claiming that
they're anti-fun they're the heroes and
the protectors and the saviors when in
reality
could you imagine like all of everything
this country went through to
stop this narrative this line of
anti-fascists
the soviets the berlin wall that we
fought a cold war
you know whatever whatever whatever that
means by fighting it and there were
several times where we nearly and
we nearly annihilated the entire planet
you guys know that story about like the
guy in the submarine
the russian guy the russian guy and then
like they got a notification like an
alert that
us had fired nukes and he refused to
retaliate and it was a false alarm
we were on we're on the brink of
something truly catastrophic
and what we're seeing now with anti-fuzz
insidious
and it's it's it's it's getting
mainstream support we'll see now now
they're kind of getting banned and stuff
and getting struck and down
so his name was uh vasily alex
alexandrovich
uh archipov yes and he was a soviet navy
officer
yeah i just looked up yeah he's
attributed to saving the world
russian submarine guy and you'll find
him on google he refused he's like i'm
not he had the
uh the mis he was misinformed and told
to fire that that well there was a
final error and there was uh you know
warning saying
russia is under attack you have to
follow protocol protocol means launching
an attack back launch an attack back now
all of his higher uh you know commanding
officers
told him to do it he refused to he's
like that doesn't feel
right yes and then luckily he made the
right decision because we would have
been
in according to the official version of
events that we're hearing
in an absolute nuclear war that would
have devastated and we probably wouldn't
be here now
if that was the case because i mean
we're talking about thousands of nuclear
weapons between russia
and the united states they openly test
them in the desert
in the united states and we're talking
about uh you know weapons that
will bring us back to the stone age and
now these are the same weapons
yeah these are the weapons that now joe
biden has that is
fragile quivering well shaking
fingertips yeah yeah i'm i'm not super
worried about this idea this you know oh
no
now you know trump's got the nukes now
biden's got the name there's just too
much power in my opinion
yeah i don't care if it's i don't care
if it's biden i don't care if it's trump
that's way too
you have you have a button that could
wipe out the entire world
ten times over uh and also other planets
like um that's too much power for one
person i was thinking we'll look back on
humans and be like they
that was the time when they still had
one guy leading all of them like a slave
driver you they had a governor leading
yeah that one guy would control them all
so that's that's an overstatement like
joe biden has power
but but then we have governors and then
we have mayors like we have a system
where we give all the power to one
person where they get to control
all this all of us symbolically right
very weird i mean the guys in black
suits really have the power but but but
i mean we have three branches and even
every state has three branches not the
gov well the governor has massive power
though and
the courts can overrule them and the
legislatures can overrule it should they
have to
yeah they should think that should that
system be in place where one guy can do
crazy stuff all the time and then yes
we have to have all these groups and
courts like yes do you think that the
system requires an individual
to have that why because direct
democracy failed every time it was tried
and anarchic societies collapsed every
time it was tried
i wouldn't i wouldn't assume the only
other option is direct democracy though
what's the other option direct
republicans the reason we have three
branches
is because in a system with distributed
decision making you can't respond to
threats fast enough
so that's kind of where i hit the wall
the threat like the military threat
what do you do when there's a military
threat that's why we have a command you
have to have one guy one commander who
can pull it but maybe the
commander-in-chief shouldn't be the
president
no i think it makes perfect sense well
now guys he only runs the executive
branch the meaning
meaning he can tell the dea not to
arrest people for pot
he can't change the law though so the
courts can still overrule his executive
orders
it i think it's it was a brilliant
system the problem is over time
too much power is being coalesced in the
executive branch and that's why there
was a light at the end of the tunnel for
the trump administration
he forced the federal government to
attack the executive branch like crazy
taking away powers from the executive
orders it was hilarious watching the the
establishment have to destroy
what they've built for so long now of
course biden's rebuilding it like crazy
that's why i didn't want to see him back
in the presidency yeah our system's not
perfect but it's
you know getting almost there it's
pretty good it's pretty legitimate if
it's actually run
the way it's supposed to be and not by
special interests and lobbyists and guys
with black suits
with special interests but but guys
don't worry everything's going to be
fine because we
right now have a very diverse former
board member of raytheon
that now runs the pentagon so now the
bombs that are going to be dropping
inside of the middle east they're going
to be very woke bombs uh you know filled
with lgbtq
slogans and everything's great guys i
got i got one better for you
that may be luke but the good news is
from news 9 abc rep green files
articles of impeachment against
president joe biden
and is that is that her she's wearing a
mask says trump won yep that sounds like
and uh
that's really it she's citing barisma
and the ukraine scandal
and i believe she mentions russia and
china and the biden's enriching their
family
you know i i talked a bit about this
earlier today and i'm not sure i'm
all that interested in what and the
point of it because
a lot of people don't know this the
democrats actually filed for impeachment
of trump several times
in december of 2017 they introduced
articles of impeachment that got 58
votes
it was shot down by almost everybody but
they really were
trying to impeach trump before he did
anything
i don't see the point of this i mean
maybe it sends a message
if you're going to accuse trump of doing
something we'll then
impeach you for the same thing and when
you strike it down it proves the double
standard
maybe that's the reason if it is i just
say this like we know there's a double
standard it's not a cop
so it's so petty like it's like if a kid
spits on a kid and then the other kid's
like
and then spits on him back like come on
didn't jesus teach you anything
turn the other cheek boom jinx you owe
me a coke
i don't i don't see what the what what
it would really accomplish
i understand it'll feel good i'm sure
there's a lot of people who are like
yeah you show them we'll impeach you
back
yeah and i'm sitting here like i'm
looking at a chess board bro and when
someone like makes a move and you just
copy that move you're not really gonna
win
i mean some people do play that well
just like try and copy their opponent
and try and find a weak point or
something
but in terms of like actual strategy you
want to be thinking about what they're
going to be doing next and not just
following behind them
it's symbolic just like most politics
it's all a
horse and pony show uh but who knows
maybe the democrats will take it
seriously
we'll impeach biden to have the kamala
presidency
which potato potato uh
but uh obviously this is just you know
people vying for attention
vying for media clicks and it's getting
clicks we're talking about it
and uh again it's not really going to
achieve anything
she's going to be on the show one day
and you're going to have to call our
kamala
yeah i don't know about that because
then she might like arrest us jesus
i think the thing is that's the problem
a lot of these people are cool in person
but
the system is so psychotic i don't think
kamala is cool
i think i think most people are pretty
cool um obviously everyone's got their
issues but when you get them one-on-one
most people are pretty much well she's a
career she'll do anything she's a
careerist she'll do
anything anything to make sure her
career gets uh progressed and luke means
it because everybody knows her history
yes and we don't want to get you know
what you know her history
i know a little bit of it yeah tell me
well she she was in her she was in a
very
um affectionate relationship it was
mayor willie brown right yes
yeah he actually was uh he actually
talked about getting um
what what tell the kids family friendly
to the children what let's just say
there was a explanation of some unfair
family-friendly things that helped
kamala harris you know move forward
but they say that she like slept their
way to the top yes correct well to start
i've heard that and i i know that she
kept people in prison in california that
were just to
make them beyond their profit can you
tell me about that well to make them
fight fires for a dollar an hour
and so a lot of people don't realize
this kamala harris was accused by tulsi
gabbard
and many others of keeping people in
prison
um longer than they should have been in
exchange for to use them for cheap labor
there's two things they don't realize
first they weren't supposed to be
released
they had parole opportunities and kamala
harris was like nah don't let him go why
we need people to fight fires for free
look if you want to tell somebody we're
going to make you you know clean the
road or
or make shoes or license plates that's
using them for cheap labor
telling them we're going to keep you in
prison and then make you risk your lives
in a wildfire
is slavery was it like confirmed that
she specifically denied parole because
she wanted them to stay or did she deny
them parole and then
it was convenient it was to further her
career because as a prosecutor if she
got losses if she got
her victories overturned she didn't look
as successful
as she would against all the other
prosecutors who had more convictions
than her more successful cases
and this is the kind of psychotic uh you
know nature
of american prosecutors believing that
they always have to win
regardless if the person who's being
convicted is innocent or not innocent
that's just crazy to think of that this
is incentivized
in a way where people really pay the
ultimate price with their freedom
with their life over someone's career
and sadly
a lot of people choose career over doing
the right thing and a lot of those
people
are rewarded and it's rewarded
it's way too many people who would do it
yeah way too many people so
i i see some of the same thing where we
are like okay it's a short term you
probably shouldn't do the short term
thing just to make yourself feel good i
think that kamala did a lot of the short
term thing just to make herself get
ahead
and she's like this is how i'm going to
rise to the top it's by lying it's by
doing takers nice thanks to a nice
people
what did she lie about so she she she
what she did was she
she took horrible advantage of the the
prisoners in california
like she took she laughed about
arresting parents yes because the
homeless women because their kids
wouldn't go to school and things like
that
she she arrested tons of people on pot
charges and then laughed about
you know how she would smoke herself she
hid evidence she hid evidence
from from people that she knew were
innocent just to further her career
yeah yeah and then she later was like
i'm so sorry that happened it wasn't my
fault it was a staff member
one of her staff members tried evidence
no no no i'm sure well
look if you were to ask me it was her
and she was proud of it up until she
realized
if you want to run on the democrat
ticket you need progressives behind you
you got to pretend to at least pander to
him
you know what i mean so she can't come
out and be like i'm all about locking up
innocent people they wouldn't vote for
that
she has to pretend to be on the side of
justice well no one voted well i guess
technically they voted for her ticket
now yeah no one voted for in the primary
no no
let's let's be real no no one no okay
not no one i would say probably 25
percent
of people only 25 percent of those who
voted actually voted for joe biden
and kamala harris why because of all
those sweet beautiful votes that biden
and camel got those were actually votes
against trump
it was the media narrative it was
driving people as hard as possible
it was a tremendous effort and my
respect to the democrats are pulling
this one off of early voting
and mail-in voting and these initiatives
they got passed and you know a lot of
republicans actually helped him
and that was the secret but i would say
the overwhelming majority of people who
cast a ballot for biden
don't care about biden don't like him
don't know what he wants
i'll tell you what's really funny
someone asked a journalist asked the
press secretary about joe biden's stance
on abortion
and she goes well um i'll tell you he's
a devout catholic
thank you oh and then everyone's like oh
she dodged the question she doesn't want
to admit it and i'm like no dude she
doesn't know the answer because joe
biden didn't campaign on anything he was
sleeping in his basement hoping people
hated trump enough to vote for him
instead
new york was it was it new yorker they
said uh stay alive joe biden yes
we just need your corp yeah the atlantic
stay alive joe biden was the name of the
article we just need your corporeal form
that's insane they wanted kamala harris
to be president
and tulsi gabbard she fired off a
nuclear bomb
took out kamalaris campaign like that it
was beautiful
it was sponge totally beautiful well
they were all bringing themselves down
kamala went hard after joe biden
you know i can't even mention what she
called them she is the
you can she's the first vice president
to have stated she believes
yes she can't say it's funny that she
believes joe biden is a sexual abuser
yes yes so she was one of the first
people to come out and say that
publicly i like to answer your question
eating i met a lot of politicians i've
been around them especially when i was
confronting them but
when you look look them in the eyes when
you're around them you feel a certain
energy when you meet new people
a lot of them are really dark empty
people that that have a
very negative vibe to say the least when
you're around them that's just eerily
and creepy especially individuals like
henry kissinger
i talked to him about six times every
time i looked him in his eyes it's this
like
insane nasty um energy
you know you talk about energy a lot of
people are just energy but but you there
is something to say about when you meet
someone
you either like them or don't like them
right away when you first meet them
based off
either you know your subconscious your
micro
expressions or some people say something
even deeper you know your kind of
energetic
field that that you represent that you
are your your vibe as as some people say
yeah like if you you can tell if someone
likes themself or hates themself when
you meet them
and it's subtle but like if you get that
dark energy usually because they they
don't
like something about who they are what
they've done and like if those people
are doing
sadistic things because of the system
that they're a part of
then they probably hate themselves deep
down or like yeah how can you
not how can you not knowing that there's
so many people suffering
because of your actions your
consequences that you could have helped
you could have literally taken people
out of jail that were innocent
save them but you kept them in there in
horrible unspeakable
in unspeakable conditions to further
your career donald trump could have done
it
yes in so many different ways yeah he
could have pardoned a lot of people
and he didn't do it yeah yeah so i don't
i've never really had a whole lot of
confidence in the system
so i i never really bothered to vote
until this
past few months donald trump winning
convinced me that voting mattered
cause i'm like wow they're freaking out
voting really had an impact you know and
then he lost
and then on his way out he didn't he
didn't drop the hammer man
it's a it's a bummer he did the opposite
he hit himself with the hammer
yeah he beat himself senselessly and
everyone's looking bewilderingly like
what but first he melted the hammer into
the shape of a cue
and then he hit himself with it yeah
well check this out
from modernhealthcare.com hhs freezes
rule targeting community health centers
and drug discounts
now that title alone probably doesn't
say a whole lot to you you're probably
like tim what is this story
this is a story about essentially joe
biden signing an executive order
that reverses trump's rules to reduce
the cost of epipens
and insulin long story short it would
seem that joe biden is trying to make
insulin and epipens more expensive
i'd like to give a round of applause to
all the leftists who want universal
health care and cheap
low-cost goods for your vote for joe
biden which results in the cost of
life-saving medications going up
do you guys remember that story about
the guy who was a minimum wage or
whatever and he couldn't afford insulin
so he was like not buying enough and
then he died he was diabetic and people
were like he needed
he tried launching a gofundme to raise
like 30 bucks or 50 bucks
to buy insulin and he couldn't do it
then he died it's a horrifying story man
so sad that was like someone just being
saying please man i just need
my medicine making me think of martin
shkreli but uh yeah the pharmaceutical
rep
pharma bro yeah jack the price up on
certain drugs like seven thousand
percent or something i don't remember
the number but there's also another
viral video
showing a young mother crying because
she can't afford the medicine for her
child
and a lot of people are sending this
video being like why isn't this problem
being addressed why is why are medical
costs
so high comparatively to so many other
places in the world
it's insane it's almost criminal in some
ways some of it
some of the arguments are bad some of
the arguments are good like when trump
signed the executive order saying
you in canada you can get insulin and
epipens for dirt but in the u.s they're
ridic their price
so high because of this weird broken
system we have so we signed this
executive
or i don't know it's let me read this
let me read this they say hhs signed off
on a rule
in december shortly before uh donald
trump left office it aims to lower
patients out of pocket costs by forcing
community clinics to pass
their drug discounts the rule requires
federally qualified health centers
to give their discounts to the uninsured
it was originally cited to take effect
january 22nd
but hhs delayed it until march 22 the
biden team could eventually withdraw the
rule
to prevent it from taking effect at all
so i guess they've
they've put a hold on it trump was
trying to make sure
as people on the left were demanding
universal healthcare
notably saying insulin and epipens so
trump was like i'm gonna sign this
saying
you can get cheaper drugs joe biden's
like nah you know why
because the pharma pharmaceutical
companies are lining his pocket with
gold
it's kind of weird cause he was obama
was all about lowering the cost of drugs
he said that yeah at least he did he
said that a lot it seemed like
that was with obama with uh the health
care
that obama said that a lot but trump
actually cared about
the people who actually had to take
insulin and epinephrine
like he actually cared about people who
really really needed this stuff from day
to day
whereas i don't i did not get that vibe
from obama he always
obama always seemed to cater more to the
elites
trump always seemed to actually care
about people who work day-to-day i don't
know maybe i'm crazy
that was really the vibe i got from
trump even though he was like a top-tier
golden toilet type person you know what
i mean yeah well we have to understand
our medical system
is utterly corrupt and incentivizing it
by throwing a whole bunch of government
money at it is not going to solve that
problem
at all it's only going to make it worse
it's a corrupt institution
that takes advantage of people i mean
i've heard horror stories of individuals
going into hospitals and getting
bills that of course will leave them in
debt for the rest of their existence
and their children's existence until
they say i don't have insurance and then
their bills are lowered 10 times what
they were it happened to me
yeah that happened to me yeah it
happened to you it happened to many
other people that i know as well and
what kind of system
do we have when literally people are
preferring to take ubers
rather than ambulances ambulances for
thousands of dollars
so i i was uh i was at skating uh i'm
chilling
and all of a sudden i got an extreme
pain probably the worst pain i've ever
felt in my abdomen yep
and i was like i fell down like to my
knees like
oh like it was it was it was
mind-blowingly painful
and so it starts to subside a little bit
and i'm like i don't know what this
could be it could be an appendix rupture
i could be like i heard when you get
appendicitis you have like the pain hits
and you have very little time
so i called the cam called an uber uh
uber pulled up and i went to the
hospital and turned out a kidney stone
it's extremely painful and it's when
what people don't realize too because i
watch too many movies
it's traveling from your kidney through
your ureter so it's like an internal
organ thing from your kidney
yeah and that's why it hurts so i went
to the hospital they didn't know it was
wrong they gave me a ridiculous amount
of drugs
and then i it's it stays for a while
like i had to go back
uh you know several days later because
because it started i started getting hit
by the pain again
and this time they figured it out uh i
ended up getting a bunch of crazy drugs
and then i got the bill in the mail and
it was i think was like like
25 thousand dollars for money for god
yeah yeah some ridiculously high number
and so i called them and i was like this
can't be right it was like an overnight
stay in the hospital and a prescription
and then i had another overnight stay
and they were like no the bill is
correct and everything you know
just give us your insurance and i was
like i don't have insurance because it
was the week i had just left vice and
before i joined fusion
where i lost for like four days
insurance
and they went oh one second let us send
you the updated bill and it was like
three thousand
seven hundred so they were like oh you
don't have insurance then we're not
going to extort your insurance company
and or they they do these deals but i
will say with respect to fusion
uh when i told them what happened they
agreed you know they were like don't
worry man we'll take care of you we
don't want you to put out
so they covered the cost for me well
that's cool that was cool of that shout
out to confusion
i mean while they who runs that company
sounds like cool dudes i know you had a
tumultuous time there
that it was the uh uh president of the
company cool the president and the ceo
taking care of your employees i was like
you know look i just left vice and i had
insurance and these four days before i
started with you guys i'm apparently not
covered i didn't realize this i thought
it was going to transfer over and
they're like no no no you don't worry
any
at all we got it we'll take care of you
anything i need to do i literally go to
mexico
and they have better service way better
prices
uh and and they take care of you i mean
i had dental work done in the united
states i had it done
in croatia colombia poland way better
service
one-tenth of the cost uh and just every
i mean i remember being in in colombia
literally uh i don't know if i should
get into some of the details here
uh but frog venom injected into your
scars
that was mexico that was mexico that was
when i did combo on my youtube channel
and if you want to see me puke and do
other stuff that are pretty interesting
check out
what was the change what was that like
it was intense and it was absolutely
crazy
and yes you could see that type of stuff
on my channel but
and in colombia they literally had these
huge
massage chairs right they had a neck
pillow
they had collagen lip masks they had
this
desensitizer that they they put in your
mouth
to numb your mouth before they they do
any work that you didn't even feel the
needle it was this like new
vibration technology that they like
i was like okay we're going to numb you
now they did it i'm like when are you
going
and then they're like we already did i'm
like what this is insane
they had a huge television not you know
on the side
but literally in the ceiling they gave
me a remote they gave me
these proper headphones they had the
most beautiful gorgeous
nurses you could ever imagine oh hey
senor can we help you oh you want
something to drink
whatever you want they had an open bar
and and then one tenth of the cost would
work that was
absolutely beautifully done um
in in places like columbia is that is
that free market or is that universal
system that's
um that was you know i paid for it yeah
um
i i i forgot exactly what the exact
system that they have there because i
i've been doing medical tourism forever
lefty's telling me everybody's got
universal health care so well how about
that
is there like insurance companies that
will cover you no matter where you go in
the world
well if it's urgent yes but a lot of
insurance companies are scams
so i mean whether it's you know
the the extra insurance you get there's
always little provisions
there's always little things and there's
always surprises that kind of catch you
literally you look like you have
something to do yeah so i worked in a
hospital for a while and i really
started to think so the first thing that
luke told me when i told him that i was
sick he's like we're going to go to
mexico
you're crazy and he's like yeah no it's
actually a thing and i was like oh maybe
so
because the u.s healthcare system i know
is an absolute sham you're absolutely
correct
and i do think that the american health
insurance system really is a scam too
because they're a little bit like the
american college system in that they
jack up their prices
to meet what the insurance company will
pay that's a problem because the
insurance company will pay whatever they
ask
exactly and then my insurance i had
insurance right
and and they wouldn't cover any of my
dental work and i'm like what do you do
what that why am i paying for insurance
you're not even going to cover my work
literally so happy in colombia
uh beautiful country uh and an
interesting fact about colombia they
actually have this
the the same record amount of cocaine
production like they did in the 80s
but with huge dramatic reductions of
violence so they're trying to make it
tourist friendly
uh and this is where we make the cocaine
yeah
i hear amazing things about it so record
cocaine production
and the most increased of increased
amount of peace
that has uh that colombia has had in a
very long time so
a lot of amazing history i know a very
beautiful place
i know tons of people yeah like i know
people from the suburbs of chicago who
are like middle class
and you know like yo what up i'm like
i'm going to mexico for vacation oh no
i'm getting out of work done
yeah i know too many people they tell me
that because they're like
the amount of money it costs you to fly
there and then the amount for the dental
work is cheaper than going to a dentist
in america you don't
see it sounds like bad american business
sounds like their outsourcing jobs
and you know maybe that's that's free
trade and we gotta
so it's connected to like the the
education industry that charges insane
rates for a
person to go become a dentist they gotta
spend six to eight years or whatever go
to medical school
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
for
whether that's even questionable whether
you actually need all that schooling or
if you just need the real world ability
to do it
um i i got i got a wisdom tooth pulled
by this dude who i
didn't seem like he knew what he was
doing anybody probably went to school
well he still didn't really know he's
like that one's in there he took a
chisel
so yeah you can go to school and just
kind of breeze your way through and
still not know what you're doing so it's
weird that all you need is a piece of
paper and then you can officially become
a doctor
um obviously you got to have a real
ability but
you know doctors aren't they don't study
health and fitness necessarily they just
study medicine
so if you're a do a doctor of osteopath
you
you study everything that somebody needs
to actually like be healthy
if you're an md you study only the
things that are wrong with people which
i could understand being an issue
because people complain about only
seeing the things that are wrong with
people
so i think your question might be with
do's or with md's it's
it's such a massive overhaul of the
system that we need to do if we want to
make the medical industry
not charge a million dollars to the
insurance agency which is
it's always these kids by the by the
balls who are like
dentists and doctors it's not it's not
so easy though because no it's not you
got millions of jobs tied into that
right and overhauling that would mean
terminating those jobs a lot of
parasitic jobs but it's still jobs
right yeah people got to feed their
family that's so weird so they're like
sorry
we it's it's already there sorry it's
damaging you what are we gonna do
you know i guess the challenge is uh
ignorance and ideology
if you can go and look at how good the
system works in a different country
and then you know a lot of people in
life will try to extrapolate data and
say look we could do it here when the
populations are dramatically different
and the resource availability is very
different
so it's hard to do it's hard to do it's
hard to figure out how we actually
fix this broken system a lot of people
say let the free market decide and it
would solve everything
the left disagrees and they think you've
got to have hard regulation so
we already have hard regulations no no
well so so what they think is
you've got to mix an amalgam of private
and regulation
mashed together in a weird way that
doesn't work properly and i think that's
true like trying to have a private
health insurance system
but regulated to the point where it
doesn't function properly just gives us
a broken system
so i'm kind of like pick one i don't
care you know i need to pick one and
then we'll start there and try and fix
it that's what's happening in the u.s
because we have like
a lot of different components we're not
fully socialized or
not fully capitalistic it's just a mess
and it's a huge problem for everyone who
has to use it which is like
literally everyone you have to like go
to the doctor at some point you have to
go to the er at some point and
every time it's like a huge bill on you
and it's like
what what a mess between the insurance
company and the actual hospital
yeah get a checkup check your blood
levels yeah i'd like so we
we started this segment talking about
joe biden and he was
rescinding this uh here's the tweet mary
vaught says biden reversed trump's
executive order to reduce
pricing for insulin and epinephrine
democrats want higher insulin prices
from bloomberg government
well you get what you get when you vote
for joe biden but my friends there's
also another story we have where we can
talk about what you get when you vote
for the likes of bernie sanders or
not so much bernie but those who would
push
policies like bernie take a look at this
year image why we got good old
bernie sanders and he's he's sitting
he's sitting in a little chair and he's
got these big old mittens on
and this this photo became a very viral
meme it is bernie sanders at the
inauguration he's kind of just like
it was over with and a lot of people
mentioned those mittens were just so
awesome
oh my god amazing mittens right right
ian you said yeah they were
they were beautiful beautiful mints what
if i were to tell you
that you will never be able to get those
mittens you
fascist no socialists you know why why
the woman who made those mittens went
out of business because the taxes were
too high and it destroyed
her business wow yeah yep the story from
the federalist woman behind bernie
sanders iconic mittens quit
making them because high taxes killed
her business how ironic
yeah that happened yeah it's like a fire
truck on fire
the guy who advocates for higher taxes
is wearing the mittens of someone who
can't make them anymore because taxes
destroyed her business i'd like to give
a round of applause again
you know look there is there's an
appropriate middle ground there's
negotiations and there's there's a way
to move forward but i think we see too
much on the left is
zealotry zealotry in the sense where
it's like
we didn't plan this we don't know what
the results will be but we really
believe it to be true so we're gonna do
it anyway
and so then you get this federalist says
the vermont school teacher who made
bernie sanders mittens featured in the
most recent viral meme
said she had to stop making them after
the federal government taxed her too
much
people have been contacting me thinking
they can get mittens and actually they
can't i don't have any more
i don't have much of a mitten business
anymore because it really wasn't worth
it
jen ellis explained to slate independent
crafters get really taken for a ride by
the federal government
we get taxed to the nth degree and it
really it wasn't really worth it
pursuing that as a business even as a
side hustle
oh man why not even talk about it
a punch in the gut seriously
you know we've talked about it a lot a
lot of conservatives do free market
capitalist types
if you tax people too much there's no
incentive to actually do anything
why do it yep what do you get i kind of
live that life man i'm just skating
right now because i don't want to deal
with it
the taxes yeah the whole system is so
annoying they just want to take take
take
regulate this regulate that like the
paperwork i mean i guess you will hire
someone else to do that stuff for you
which is great i guess if you get to
that point maybe but you still got to
pay attention if someone's handling your
finances
it's their finances so you still have to
maintain your finances
yep that's a good lesson that kanye west
talks about he's his own c
uh ceo or cfo cool yeah well many people
make the argument that taxes are
are all about controlling and keeping
people in line and
how can you not believe that when the
government literally prints money
but yet we're still supposed to be given
a portion of our income if we could
still magically earn it
if if if immigration didn't take it if
oversea
visas didn't take it we somehow
magically are able to sustain for
ourselves and
when we still have to give a huge cut to
the government that
that is going to spend it on most likely
war i mean
like are you kidding me you see look
look when we talk about taxes
the left and the left and the right
usually have the wrong conversation i
love the who will build the roads
conversation with libertarians right
so a lot of people on the left when
talking with and caps and libertarians
say
but who will pay for the roads and then
you actually get an argument and the
libertarians will say
it's going to be a private company who
maintains the roads and maybe there will
be a toll and i'm sitting there going
like uh-huh
uh-huh let me ask you the real question
who's going to bomb the kids
who's going to who's going to blow the
kids up oh guess what nobody
because there's no incentive in any
market to do it i'm not a lazy fair
capitalist mind you
okay you know i think there's problems
with overgrowth of monopolies and
monopolistic power and i don't know a
lot of people in super chats often
disagree
but i will tell you one thing the
question should be not who will build
the roads
i'll tell you this i will take no road
you can give me dirt
i will crawl through rocks if it means
we're not paying for the blowing up of
people in foreign countries
which i don't like yeah i'll gladly take
an off-road vehicle if it means not
having roads if we're not going to be
bombing the crap out of the middle east
and sending troops all over the entire
world and threatening
huge geopolitical conflicts with other
world powers
yes i'll gladly do that in a heartbeat
and people need to understand
michael bloomberg another kind of uh you
know scrooge like
individual has has made arguments that
that taxes and regulations are necessary
for
control of of the populations in order
to keep them in line lydia you have
something
right yeah so do you guys remember when
domino's pizza decided to fix the
potholes in the roads
better yeah yeah who will build the
roads
domino's pizza will yeah what no they
won't they did
they literally did there was even an
adult website that paved
uh the roads in the northeast after a
major snowstorm
because the government was having
troubles doing it that's cool so
you know there's there's a lot of
stories of of people coming to
each other's needs helping each other
out without the involvement of a
middleman when you have a middleman
that's when you have government when you
have people solving each other's
problems working
uh with each other bartering trading
that's called anarchy
and we have a lot of anarchy that no one
really wants and you don't want to admit
you know what really bothers me too you
know the government's not even really
that good at blowing up kids
private security forces are way better
at killing civilians
well they spend a lot of money on it
especially when you look at the coffers
when you look at the budgets when you
see the trillions of dollars missing in
the pentagon
you're like wait wait where did this
money go these other guys have
flip-flops
these other guys have literal little
cloth on
that's not even made as as proper
clothing and and you're
and if they're lucky they have an ak
but but we have to send hundreds of
thousands of dollars at one missile to
blow them up
why somewhere thousands of thousands of
miles away from us why
this doesn't make any sense so i think
this is a classic case of when you give
people money they will rise to meet
whatever you will give them because i
found this to be the case with military
budgeting so with the planes and stuff
they're like well we won't charge this
much unless they'll
pay this much like donald trump found
that the plane
uh makers would make planes for like one
half the cost
they're like well we were just making
planes because this is what they would
give us
like that's capitalism for you but at
the same time it's like if the
government subsidizes it that's an issue
that's not capitalism right you have
socialism
yeah when the government says we're
going to be listen
you should think about money in terms of
buying power and access to resources and
not
you know people think about money think
about a number a hundred dollars five
hundred dollars a thousand
no no think about what you can get for
it if you make 15 bucks an hour i don't
care
i don't i i don't care listen right now
you got all these lefties saying we
should get 15
an hour living wage okay so here's what
the government's done
you will get your raise quick print
money to reduce their buying power so
they don't actually get anything
if you can only buy you know let's say
15 buys you
a pair of blue jeans and then they give
you a raise of 15 an hour but then
increase the cost of blue jeans to 30
bucks you didn't get a raise
you just think you did and that's a
brilliant way to keep people
dumb and happy yeah i got a big raise
well there's a reason a lot of the top
billionaires call for more taxes and
more regulations because it
kills and squeezes out their competitors
anyone who's willing to compete against
them anyone
who could defeat them anyone who could
overcome them
is is burdened with all these other
things that they have to deal with
when these guys could just skate right
through it it's no issue for them it's
not a problem for them but everyone else
is going to be struggling
there's there's a picture of this pool
and it's showing a little small business
and it's showing an adult in there the
adult is amazon it's all these other top
big companies and then the little kids
are small businesses
and it's a pool and they're drowning in
it and the water
are our regulations and taxes so that's
essentially what's happening now and
sadly this poor lady
i mean those mittens look look pretty
cool yeah
they look really nice but but sadly
people are going to have to go to amazon
to get their chinese-made mittens by the
uyghur muslim population most likely
according to my own personal opinion
uh incentivized you ever see those
things where like someone will buy a
box of like i don't know combs in the
open as a note saying i'm trapped in a
factory in china please say yeah
i have not seen that yeah you've never
seen those before yeah because people
working in the factories are essentially
slaves and they'll write like please
save us
and they'll put it in the box hoping
somebody gets it there's news stories
with pictures
of that stuff but the current system
that we're living on leaves us
no choice but to go to amazon because
there's no other place to potentially
buy
mittens made by the average person the
average human being the average
entrepreneur that is trying to make
their way
in this really complex really hard
economically hit
the united states it's so funny because
i could make mittens and give them to
you
but if i make mittens and sell them to
you government's like hey
we want 35 of that yeah and on top of
that sales tax
in certain states i mean are you kidding
me you ready for this
from vox.com you buy a purse at walmart
there's a note inside from a chinese
prisoner now what you were right luke
wow
you you said what do you what what start
you said amazon though oh yeah amazon
walmart and it was chinese prisoners
tracing a mysterious message across the
world to understand
how what we buy is made they say when
crystal wallace found a piece of paper
folded up at the bottom of her purse in
march 2017 she threw in the trash
she hadn't yet used the maroon bag made
by walmart and purchased from one of its
arizona stores a month months ago
but after a few minutes she got curious
she took the paper out of the waste
basket
unfolding the sheet to reveal a message
scrawled in mandarin chinese
translated red inmates in china's
yingshang prison work 14 hours a day
and are not allowed to rest at noon we
have to work overtime until midnight
people are beaten for not finishing
their work there's no salt and oil in
our meal in our meals
the boss pays 2001 every month for the
prison to offer better food
but the food is all consumed by the
prison guards sick and
inmates have to pay their own pill pay
for their own pills
prisoners in china cannot be compared to
prisoners in the united states
horse cow goat pig dog crystal's
daughter-in-law loris wallace posted a
photo of the note to facebook on april
23rd
the post first went viral locally
getting shared and liked several hundred
times
mostly by fellow arizonans after a few
days local media picked it up
and the story eventually goes viral is
today huffington post etc
one video report on the incident
accumulated 2.9 million views
so there you go how else do you think
these items are so cheap
why do you think they're so cheap like
what like
it's just crazy and mind-boggling to
understand
how this entire system works how it's
incentivized and yet we turn a blind eye
to it and totally ignore it but luke
you you have these wonderful shoes and
these pants and all these clothes and
the goods
we're all hypocrites they're made by
slaves most of them
yeah i think i think i will try a lot
harder to make sure that stuff i'm
getting made is being made fair trade
i'm wondering about the teespring who
their third party is that they meant
it's american it is oh okay yeah so they
they they actually
printed a shirt and showed me like in
real time so
they have their own you know
manufacturing but the shirts themselves
may come from overseas oh i've heard
that argument over and over again about
sweatshops where these industrial
industrialists are like well they make a
quarter an hour but they'd be making a
dime an hour
if they were you know working on a farm
so it's a good job for them
i'm like yeah but you're also taking
jobs away from americans and extracting
our economy
so you know what happens with all of
this trade and like what what's going on
with these slaves
the cheap labor means that when you have
10 bucks and you buy that product
almost all of it goes to some ultra
wealthy billionaire type
a tiny fraction goes to the chinese
government of which they use it to
barely sustain the lives of these
prisoners
your money is being siphoned away by the
ultra wealthy
who then lobby for laws to make sure you
don't ever compete with them
so what you're saying is that they're
extracting from you to prop up this
cobweb and matchstick
government or like economy in china that
sounds great
yeah you know what what maybe maybe
there needs to be some kind of like call
to action for regular people something
like
i don't know what would represent this
like not the the managers or the bosses
but maybe like the working people like
the workers
and maybe maybe everyone around the
world should come together and like
we could come up with a slogan maybe
like workers of the world
unite how about that i'm
no uh it's it's really it's really is a
shame that workers of the world united
associate with communism though
that's what lenin's thing is that was
that one of his rallying clubs it's the
communism thing it's like workers of the
world united
yeah there definitely needs to be more
collective bargaining there's definitely
not enough
about you know with that i mean we hear
horror stories not just in china but
also
local uh factories in in the united
states when it comes to
amazon warehouses halt sir we need more
decentralization
yeah we shouldn't have these massive
monopolies like amazon controlling
everything yeah we should unite
but it's just how you unite no it no i
disagree
we should decentralize maybe we should
unify decentralization as sounds pretty
legit
yeah if we if we didn't have amazon
walmart targeting these big box stores
being allowed to stay open because the
government is propping them up while
shutting down small businesses
you know if we had small mom and pop
shops that were all over the place
that's that that's the kind of
decentralization we need instead they're
centralizing everything
it's only a matter of time before amazon
does everything literally everything
yeah and they're lecturing us about
social justice
and and lgbtq issues and about what's
what's
that there's so many we got to start
making skits because i have some really
great ideas of like
just like an ultra wealthy guy counting
hundred dollar bills and then he looks
at he looks like it's the coal miner and
goes
racist he's just counting his money
again we gotta get ryan long and tim
dillon on and then
bring them here for a weekend and then
just do a crap ton of skits
in front of the green screen okay i'm
going to mess around let's mess up
you ever see the comic where there's
like a middle class guy with a few
cookies
and then there's an ultra rich guy with
a huge plate of cookies and he's yelling
and pointing at the poor guy with no
cookie yeah and the middle class guy is
looking angry at the poor guy
and i'm like you could make the exact
same comic if you change the races of
the people who are looking at each other
because all they've done is once they
realized people
workers of the world were actually kind
of uniting not in a communistic way but
against the establishment this was
occupy wall street
so they threw in identity politics to
make everybody fight each other
and it works so perfectly they started
obsessing about it on the mainstream
media and in the culture
and they started pushing this narrative
and everyone followed and everyone got
their little talking points and they
repeated them
perfectly and it and as you said i it
worked
but i think there's also an element
pushing it through the algorithms to
make it seem like it works more
effectively than we
than we realize so i think there's also
the gaming
of perception that is happening that is
also an important aspect to understand
here because when we're looking at the
timelines when we're looking at the
algorithms
it's usually the most radicalist the
most craziest the most insane stuff
highlighted
to us and that's the perception that
people get of other leftists or other
people on the right
and i think that also is based on an
illusion that is perpetrated
that wants you to believe those things
because it pushes that agenda and drives
you further
into those kind of uh ideologies take a
look at the story about
the people in germany being put in
either refugee camps
or in detention in hospitals and they're
they're you know
some of the people uh you know some of
our friends were saying that
their lefty friends couldn't find any of
those stories and so i have i've
actually encountered this and maybe you
guys listening have as well
there there i have a ton of friends who
are very very very lefty some social
justice warriors
we argue all the time but you know we've
been friends for a lot longer than the
culture wars existed so we kind of just
you know move on with our lives
but there have been times where i've
been like wow did you hear about x
and they'll say that's not true i'll say
google it they'll be like there's
nothing here
and they'll try and google they don't
see anything because the algorithmic
feeding of information
so i have to send them a link and then
finally like push that story into their
bubble
and then google will start
algorithmically feeding it facebook will
start
but it's probably true that like if you
go to r politics on reddit
it is all left-wing agenda there's there
it's like donald trump is bad bernie
sanders is good oh if you go on reddit
it's like
it's remarkable how er early on in you
know 2015-16
donald trump posts pro-trump posts were
dominating reddit
now it's aoc posts like she's literally
the same thing as donald trump
and their politics are different no it's
no you'll see
more aoc posts than cat posts i'm not
kidding in fact when i go to r slash all
no algorithm it's just all the posts
there will be like two or three posts
there's like
there's r slash aoc there's r slash
murdered by aoc
then there's like our slash our
president and progressive and it's
always a tweet from aoc going like
republicans are trash
they're so trash i'm so smart things
like that tim tim i'm sure this is
because the only people in the world
are leftists who all agree with aoc i'm
sure this topic
top post on reddit reddit.com hot
popular what brings the worst out in
people
that's a question it's just the most
popular thing on reddit right now they
want to talk about that stuff that's
fine
the worst what's the worst think of
getting i remember last time it was
charlie kirk as a white supremacist
and i don't even like charlie kirk but i
think calling him that is extremely
disingenuous and fake and extremely
hyperbolic and sensational that leads to
the destruction of our language
and from any rational political
discourse and i remember a long time ago
when reddit was this free-flowing
amazing place and you would get
really interesting wonders and
interesting creations and now is just
more and more political just like
everything like like can we not just be
political all the time can we stop that
youtube uh you know can you just focus
on maybe creating a
video platform rather than playing
politics same could be said for music
for art it's just like
so i i pulled up reddit i'm on r slash
all all posts
first post nothing to do with politics
what is it it's a freezer full of mold
oh good or something
second the real things that matter no
politics third post no politics
fourth post giving me hope three act
maga tragedy
it's a woman complaining about trump
fifth post joe biden's executive order
is gonna help unemployment and blah blah
blah
pro-biden political so that's four and
five political and these are by up votes
yeah like the most upvoted then we have
another
another post so number number six is not
political seven is not political
number eight biden press secretary
jensecki is not playing when asked why
biden wasn't prioritizing
republican issues in the name of unity
she said is it unemployment insurance
not a republican priority
are schools opening safely not a
republican priority oh smack
snap it's moderate right next post pro
bernie sanders meme
the next post is not political not
political
and not political and then not political
so there we go
next four of ten right the next post
political the next
post is arguing against unity the next
post is political
it's all it's like a third it was like i
should i should say pro-democrat
oh yeah are they they're moderating that
right like the moderators will go in and
well they they they banned uh the donald
because it was too popular
so i would say what do we have what do
we have now about 50 percent have been
pro democrat here's another one
not the onion capital riders express
regret after not getting pardoned
the next post is anti-donald trump pro
hunter biden
it's it's just non-stop it's just
non-stop every other
every other post is just pro democrat
political
the time ted cruz got bamboozled texas
deserves better says a woman
oh it's endless yeah endless reality tv
well you still no it's
all pro democrats people getting in
there talk about politics is reality tv
it's like the modern day
well it used to be about comedy it used
to be about creation
it used to be about art it used to be
about just wonders that you wouldn't
find anywhere travel photos and
interesting facts that you wouldn't get
anywhere else useful tips
and now it's just cultism it denigrated
to cultism as you say and it's listen
it's it's sad
if you want to go to a forum dedicated
donald trump i wouldn't call that
cultism if you want to go to a form
dedicated to aoc i wouldn't call that
cautism
if the entirety of the website is
dominated by people just mindlessly
upvoting the same pro-democrat stuff
now you're getting yourself some kind of
problem to be fair it's probably paid
companies
democratic organizations probably hire
people to astroturf
and sock puppet on reddit to make people
think that it's pro-democrat
and then what they do is they lobby
reddit to ban conservatives which
they've done
over and over and over again so there
you go welcome to the to the new era
so when they do this can you blame
conservatives for really
wanting there to be a space where people
just agree with them for a change
i'm not even about agreeing with them a
place where they won't get banned for
saying somebody
like i don't know well parlor's gone
they got they got um
exploded yeah i don't do the identity
politics stuff anymore
i want neutral platforms i think it's
not going to happen
i just want a reddit that used to be
reddit you know yeah i want a youtube
that was just
youtube and just focused on helping
people create
videos helping people express themselves
and they don't do that well the problem
the problem is
you now have communities.win which is a
bunch of different
you know exiled communities you had vote
for a while when red started banning a
bunch of you know
different types of like i think fat
people hate got banned and it was where
people just rag on fat people all day
so they got banned and then vote was
very similar to reddit and then they had
their own you know thing and then
the oat vote yeah but then vote got
dominated by a bunch of the exiled
alt-right types
and so then the media attacked them now
you that now you have communities that
win that win is interesting because
they're like
individual websites just like somewhat
networked it's an open source code i
believe
i think the solution is going to have to
be something like the feta verse a
decentralized social media network yeah
because you're always going to have
moderators that have political agendas
and even no matter how famous your
company is you'll eventually one day
sell it
and then some new moderators with new
agendas will have it or just stop
editorializing have have a code of
conduct right have a basic set of rules
that are based on
the laws and if someone breaks a law let
the law handle it or you could
personally handle it but when you
editorialize something
you bastardize it you manipulate it and
this is why live streams were so popular
back in the day especially when we were
doing political live streams it was
unedited
it was live we didn't uh make sure
people saw certain stuff and didn't see
certain stuff
everything was shown as is it was real
life
and people loved that they enjoyed it
we met at occupy wall street you know i
was this very famous and prominent
streamer and
luke was was was walking i met you
yeah and then and then i saw luke and i
said
and then i saw luke and i said hey kid
catch and i threw him a phone
and he went oh gee thanks mean joe tim
what happened and then luke started
streaming and that was just how it's
the story i'm kidding look at a really
big channel as some random guy
you you you never produced a video when
i met you that's not true
i had several well you never were into
politics
when i met you yeah you were doing like
you were doing skateboarding but you
were never into politics and you're like
what am i doing hold on hold on yeah i
have been in politics my whole life
i wasn't producing videos of politics i
was producing videos of skateboarding
you know what
no one knew who the man was there was a
reason why i went to occupy wall street
because i was paying attention had you
been
up at occupy of course yeah yeah always
and uh i got featured in a
el salvadorian magazine i think like the
first coverage because they saw me
working and they're like who's this guy
and i started live streaming through
mobile it was very very you know
preliminary and it was like what was it
144p the dreams were like just
totally grainy garbage and then i met
luke luke had uh he had a huge channel
50 000 subscribers
and when i met luke he was like dude i
got 50 000 subscribers i was like whoa
like this channel is huge yep and then
uh
we were arguing and uh we were at some
debate for him and uh
for then i was like i like the arguments
you're making here and we just kind of
like stopped so
i met some lady was like you should meet
this guy you know he's got 50 000
subscribers yeah who is that lady i
don't remember
yeah shout out to that lady yeah was it
we are change
yeah were you streaming through youtube
or um
yeah youtube didn't have it it was
youtube stream and i remember still
making youtube videos at the time with
the big dslr having to run home having
to put it in
the sd card i remember during the raid
of occupy wall street i was
inside oh you stayed that way and and i
tried to go live but there was some kind
of interference there was something
going on they
brought up well that and also everyone
was kicked
out of there and they brought in these
like weird uh you know trucks and these
satellites and i was inside and i didn't
have a seat away from you as soon as i
was kicked out no i was inside because
they set up a perimeter and like
you're outside the perimeter like 50
feet away bro yeah i'm saying your cell
phone
should have worked but you think they
created like a zone of dead
space and people were getting the crap
beat out of them the police officers
literally brought in
um these huge tools and they were they
were cutting the the
metal that people were tied to on the
inside people were just getting clubbed
left and right people were
getting just thrown around shoved around
wildly and i remember like why can't
i film this live and i remember doing
the dslr footage
uh josh gordon-levitt was actually there
i interviewed him
right at right outside of the thing i
was able to escape the police
the actor yeah joseph yes yes and i met
joseph uh you know
yeah interviewed him i saw tim tim was
live streaming
and then i'm like i gotta go home to
edit this video because my cell phone
camera
my cell phone died uh mysteriously
and i remember six o'clock in the
morning i'm editing and then tim pulls
live with like three million viewers
22 hours for 22 hours and i'm like i
made the wrong decision here and
uh you know and then you had people
literally coming to you bringing you
batteries and food and food because i
was i was awake
i was awake for i didn't go to sleep i
was up for over 22 hours
streaming and there was a point where i
was live streaming and i couldn't open
my hand
because i was holding umbrella was that
your big break like is that the moment
that you
exploded onto the mainstream kind of i
would say a hundred percent i remember
talking about
millions your feed was on all the
mainstream media channels
like 250 million yes yes yes but it was
a blip sweep it went up and right back
down
yeah that was the name and i had a bunch
of these flavor of the month offers
where they were like write a book
join this tv show and i basically was
like nah nah nah give me guarantees give
me guarantees
now this news the famous you know lefty
they tried hiring me as their like
third person as like their main first
correspondent whatever i was like nah
because what i wanted to do was i wanted
to run my own thing and slowly build up
a proof of a career everybody saw that
massive spike
and they knew they could latch on to
what i had done for some instant pr
and i told him to go f off and then a
year later
i went to vice and said hey look i'm
still working it's still
i'm still working what i'm doing is
still working we've gotten way more
press
and they said i like i like how that
sounds
google wanted me to do stuff on youtube
they wanted me to
like create this methodology and
technology and so when vice found out
and they found out i want to work for
them then they were like hey google
you know that guy you were trying to get
we hired him what are you gonna give us
and then google was like okay let us
know what you want and then i worked for
vice for a while
and then i went to work for disney and
then you know here we are do you guys
remember at occupy a couple nights
before they raided the park
um well it might have been a week before
bank of america just all of a sudden
decided to start doing street work
street construction right outside the
park across the street you know bank
america was right across the street from
zuccotti
yeah um you mean you mean chase i
thought it was bank of america
uh right before uh right like right
after occupy started
chase did lobby construction and
barricaded off the entire plaza they
started doing street construction
like drills and like jack cameron was
also out there as well
and they were just noise they were
trying to get people to leave the park
because of the noise
it was insidious i remember that the
police would
park their cars next to the park at like
three in the morning and then just go
and then flash their lights onto people
and then it was it was like uh
i think that what they were trying to do
was like it's like it's a form of
torture
yep the goal was to sleep deprive people
and trick and
like not trick them but like force them
into leaving i think there was officer
lombardo who literally wasn't it was
at a guard at gitmo literally there
three o'clock in the morning kicking
people putting flashlights in their face
uh just waking up random people and i
remember filming him
and he had this like huge obsession with
me where he literally
followed me everywhere i went so i went
on like a
like a 10 block walk and he just started
walking like like right beside the cops
just looking at me
uh well so there was hipster cop
remember himself i remember hipster
so uh i remember he was like tim and he
walked over and shook my hand he's like
i followed your streams it's really good
stuff he's like i think you're being
fair
and i was like look if i was there for
that i remember yeah i was like if the
cops are hitting somebody i'm gonna film
enough the protesters are hitting
someone filament he goes that's all we
ask
i remember there was an undercover cop
and people were like hey he's an
undercover cop i'm like
what's going on here and i just started
filming randomly the undercover cop
comes and he jabs me
right in my stomach i remember that i'm
like and he's and he walks away and i'm
like you
such chased him and he jumped over the
barricades and i'm like that's it you
sent you know but hold on
you could the barricades were the police
barricades you weren't allowed to cross
them yeah so this guy
outed himself as an undercover cop yeah
by by punching me in the gut
jumping the barricades i jumped the
barricades and i went right into his
face i was like you son of a gun
and i was like you know and i just
started going off at him and i was like
officers this man assaulted me i want to
press charges and none of them would do
anything and he was walking three blocks
and i was
screaming at him and then later of
course obviously he came behind that
official police lines and other police
officers like i'm like wait wait i got
him on camera assaulting me and i wasn't
even trying to do anything i was just
filming there randomly
so yeah i got a couple batons there that
wasn't my only rough up with the police
there but there was also one incident
that i remember
huge scuffles are happening this is the
one time that occupy wall street was
actually able to get on wall street that
was their big thing it didn't achieve
anything but it was
a symbolic gesture there's huge fights
huge clashes i'm right in the middle of
it
and then the officers like hey i know
you you're luke i love your stuff
you're great man keep putting up on my
all right thanks man thanks
hey i appreciate it like there was there
was there was one time where everybody
marched to uh
uh who was the maritime was it bloomberg
i think it was bloomberg yeah they went
they went to the mayor's house and there
was a bunch of cops what they would do
is the cops would walk just off the curb
to keep the protest on the sidewalk and
i'm walking and filming and then there's
this regular beat cop and he goes
hey tim poole and i was like hey and
he's like hey and he reaches hand i
shake my hand and i'm like ah geez dude
in front of all the far left
bad optics and i was like hey he's like
i i like what you're doing man you're
being fair about it
and i was like yeah no problem and then
the leftists were like he's on the side
of the cops
he's a cop this proves it and then
occupy wall street tweeted that one day
when i got attacked
that so we told the story of the day i
got attacked and then luke pulled the
guy's mask off
occupy wall street immediately tweeted
tim poole just tried helping a cop
arrest somebody
and a bunch of the other activists who
ran that who knew i wasn't a cop
like were like what are you doing and
then deleted the tweet but i got
screenshot and started getting shared
around
and then all the crazy lefties were like
whoa tim pool was trying to help arrest
somebody
when in reality i got hit and that was
it
yeah i got hit no no no no no no no you
got hit and then my friend
me and my friend jumped in and then the
cops came and they let the guy go
who who beat you up so the guy ran away
and then you posted his face yeah well
no never found him well it was it was
there's a lot of things that
you know that happened in that little
scuffle so the guy
like judo chopped my arm while i was
holding my phone up and it hit the
ground and bounced away
and then i grabbed his arm and pulled it
and then just locked onto it and who's
some guy just some random dude well he
was all right he was black blocked
and so i grabbed his arm and locked it
and wouldn't let him go he was
struggling to get away
luke walked up and went with his mask
then a cop ran up and grabbed him and
pushed me away and the guy and let the
guy run off oh man
it was crazy so we thought the guy was
like um maybe undercover or something
why why did the cops come to save him
from me maybe they just wanted to stop
literally
literally ran in there grabbed him
pulled him out
and then he ran away that's it well they
pulled him out of the crowd and then
and just let him go they probably wanted
to end the violence there was no
violence
well you guys were struggling and they
were like no i grabbed his arm
because i didn't want there to be a
fight because i knew what they would
claim in the press and what they would
try to do
so i just held onto his arm and he was
trying to pull away and struggle
and then the cop ran up and grabbed us
grabbed me and pushed me away and then
let the guy go
it was weird i remember going in there
like pushing him holding him down a
little bit and i was like oh let me let
me see what's underneath this thing
and then yeah dude occupy because it
comes up
because there's so many undercover cops
that use black block tactics a lot of
people don't know this there's a huge
history
of police officers inciting violence
specifically
as black bloc to make sure that the
police have a reason to respond and to
crush
any dissent whether peaceful or not so
that's why i was always on the lookout
for black bloc because i knew
they could be undercover police officers
because i just got beat up
i got punched in the gut by a yeah hold
on
back to talking about being getting in
trouble for what your followers say and
do because your
followers can be like chinese plants
a corporation can hire a bunch of people
to become your followers
to incite violence in your comments
section or on your website yeah
and it's not your fault but look i want
to point out the undercovers we actually
knew were undercovers
they look like cops dude i was wearing
like a blue hoodie
no he was wearing a black hoodie and was
trying to be he's trying to look like uh
like uh like but he was like a
middle-aged dude but bucky yeah oh right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he but he was he was everyone
accused bucky of always looking like a
cop too yeah
didn't he gonna go off the rails i don't
know i think i saw him posting like uh
f trump uh flag all around new york city
and like these weird photos and i'm like
it's weird that's
uh kind of weird as well and those are
the days ladies and gentlemen those are
the old occupied days
and something magical happened you see
the powers that be realized that
people like luke rudkowski what are you
are you nan cap how do you describe
yourself
i'm i'm a free human being that i like
to like doesn't like labels
i don't i like to determine my position
after hearing free market
or cooperative i believe in personal
responsibility and freedom and
decentralization libertarian whatever
ah i don't like labels okay communist
yeah sure all right i made a video where
it said uh i took my political compass
test i turned someone to communist
we took the politicians i got this test
together and i got libertarian socialist
and i got libertarian
you got center right you got libertarian
we're like right in the same position
except you're just to the left i'm to
the right yeah
so anyway occupy wall street brought
together weirdos like luke and weirdos
like me
yeah and that's dangerous that's not
good
well it gave us a start to be able to
have a message that reached out to so
many people
i mean we're talking about endorsements
from uh the immortal technique was down
there
who else was that that rapper that was
down there that
uh that that uh was was at obama's
inauguration and talked about his drone
bombing
i don't know uh what's his name uh no
there's another one
there are so many other like celebrities
and media figures and professors and
intellectuals that came down there to
argue alec baldwin came down
lupe fiasco was down there too i
interviewed lupe fiasco roseanne barr
came down
uh what the heck yeah she's awesome
yeah yeah i'm like what the hell's going
on i'm like trying to i'm eating a gyro
and
like roseanne barr runs up to me it was
such a weird feeling but it was such a
collective word there was such
weirdness it was like the internet
exemplified
when it was still free and it was still
wild but it was in real life
and you got the crazies you got the
leftists you got the right wingers you
got the ron paulers you got the
libertarians and it was beautiful i
loved it
because it was such a random thing that
you just hit you upside the head
no no one in the media originally was
talking about it and it only got
coverage because the police officers
tried to brutalize the people
in a way yeah those women exactly
and that was the the kind of v for
vendetta moment that that lit
on fire that lit this idea amongst the
minds of many people
that's saying if you stand there if you
just sit there in a park the police will
come and they
will beat the crap out of here and it
will pepper spray four women on a street
corner
not in the protest and tony baloney
anthony bologna
walked up and just sprayed these four
women for no reason yeah
he got reassigned to staten island
because of it he was he wasn't he like
the number one he was a top cop in new
york at the time
i believe so yes and then i think
lombardo took over and he was brutal i
made a whole natural
natural national geographic piece about
the lombardo
so look up the lombardo we are changed
you're going to find a really funny
video about his just
utter abuse of power that we were
actually able to make
fun of he came up to me afterwards he
was like did you make that lombardo
video
you made that video i'm like i don't
know what you're talking about sir no
clue
what are you doing let's go to super
chats my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button hit the
notification bell subscribe
and go to timcast.com become a member
because
we're going to have a bonus segment and
i think we're actually going to go out
and film tomorrow
we're going to the range we got some
guns we're going to go to the range and
we're going to have a good time and then
you can make fun of us for not being as
skilled as you are
when it comes to proper gun etiquette
but we we will be very very safe
and we're gonna have these kind of bonus
videos where we'll talk about what we're
doing why we're doing it and our
thoughts and opinions and things but
we're gonna do a bonus segment tonight
probably we'll see how it goes
teamcast.com become a member we are very
close to the point
where i'm i'm really i'm really
surprised i'm really impressed that i'm
internally grateful to everybody
because you know just going through
memberships i'm like dude we're probably
a week away
from never having to worry about youtube
ever again and like honestly
legitimately being like we should
produce more for the website because the
website is going to be way better
and way freer and safer than youtube so
we can produce all the same content
and so this is this is fantastic stuff
so really really thank you let's read
these super chats
mind you we're never going anywhere
we're going to keep doing the shows on
youtube because there's a balance
between
the free and the members only stuff and
so i want to make sure that the most
pressing stuff will always be free for
everybody
fueled by ads and super chats and things
like that heads up on the
website too tech support's been hard at
work figuring out the problem with why
some people weren't getting responded to
and they will be getting you will be
getting response within the week
if you don't send another email and your
members
at timcast.com and you won't be charged
for any time if you subscribed like
before and you didn't get set up because
of
this internal issue you won't be your
your uh subscription will begin the day
that it goes through so you'll have 30
days from like when you finally get set
up so you're not going to miss that
i will add it is a small operation here
with a handful of people we're trying to
build the system it just launched about
a week about almost two weeks ago now
about a week and a half
so we're trying to get to the point
where we're as proficient and and
powerful as say the new york times
it's going to take time and energy so i
respect all of your patients they're
very cool give them a break
i will also add the people here are very
intelligent
yes all right we got some super chats
for everybody smash that like button
let's read matthew hammond says are they
going to tell
us if you do not like it you get to make
your own t-shirts
yeah you can make your own t-shirts
that's what we're gonna do eric douglas
says ian is the eddie bravo of the show
and i say that with the utmost respect i
love eddie
look into it let's see colin pieces adam
curry is jealous that his wife listens
to your show more than his own show no
agenda
get in touch with him he wants to come
on the show okay cool
i'm not familiar i think i've heard of
that show no agenda though i'll look him
up
yeah andrew bishop says tim kyle
kolinsky said on rogan that trump
increased drone strikes by 300 400
percent
what's your thoughts on this horrifying
and very very bad and worthy of the
utmost criticism no doubt
uh the big challenge with trump is i
didn't look
i didn't vote for him in 2016. and i
ragged on him for three years
i just thought the critics were insane
so it's like trump would do something
questionable and then the critics would
claim he kicked a puppy in the face he'd
be like dude
no he didn't calm down and then when it
came to the abraham accords and trying
to withdrawal i was like i like that
please more of that
so look we we've criticized the guy oh
he's only got to say two words john
bolton like
seriously criticize him on the drone
stuff 100
trent lamolino says michael malus was on
cash cab and i can't unsee it
did you guys find that video did he win
yeah he did pretty well he wanted his
smart guys
yeah he's super smart he's a smart fella
yeah he looks so different though he
looks really
like really you gotta watch him really
like he looks like he's like
17. yeah look it up
rhys jones says good day watch your show
all the time my wife is in la for a
course
she was refused service for being not a
local is that normal we are australian
i don't know about that weird they're
also phobic
george rrf97 says hi tim i'm a big fan
from the uk hope you guys are aware of
the storm about to hit crypto market
regarding the tether lawsuit
it's been used to buy bitcoin and could
cause a temporary crash
perhaps i don't care um you know bitcoin
was at like 40 it dropped to 30 and
everyone's like quick sell and i was
like nope
and then it bumped back up to like 38
and i'm like don't care
there's i watched this video recently
where this woman's like
in 2013 someone sent me a bitcoin and i
shrugged my soldiers and said thanks
shrugged my shoulders and said thanks
and now in 2021
she's like i realized when everyone was
screaming about bitcoin that i had one
and then she realizes she has 40 000
2013 bitcoin was at what it was like
fluctuating between 10 50 or maybe even
a hundred bucks
someone could have given you a 20 bill
in 2012.
that's 40 000. about 10 000 bitcoins man
i almost bought 6 300. this looks like
tethers
maybe was using the money tethers a
stable coin and they're supposed to
maybe hold the money when you buy it but
they were buying bitcoin with it i don't
know there's some sort of investigation
i use usdc
right now as my stable coin
omg puppy says social media was banning
people for the npc
meme a couple years ago it triggers the
sjw's badly for some reason i remember
it
because it resonates yeah a lot all my
mpc stuff has been banned
it's such a great yeah yeah wow so uh
yeah i mean i i like the mpc meme yeah
and i made a lot of mpc t-shirts all of
them are gone so
we're gonna bring them back though who's
the artist for that uh it was just it
feels like a 4chan meme wasn't it i
don't remember
man i want to meet that person npc
melissa b says dan bongino warned about
teespring during his show yesterday or
today
please be careful i mean we will but
look my shirts are
silly like me with a monocle and like a
pipe with bubbles
oh yeah ian's got one lydia thank you
very much it's medium the right size
we don't doing in the near future we
don't do crazy hyper-political shirts
that worried about getting banned
it's silly it's me like it's just a
really silly image someone made for it
but
even if you did if you made fun of the
mainstream media why is that wrong
crazy yeah like how is that it does it
does seem like they were going
on copyright grounds which means they
shouldn't have and you'll need a smarter
and better
well they shouldn't have number one it
doesn't make sense and two they they hit
other stuff that
there's no reason to hit icefox says
don't know if you have looked into
bunker branding or if they are taking
more creators but it is owned and
operated by matt from demolition ranch
it's an alternative to teespring by
youtubers for youtubers check it out
uh definitely i was looking into them
and i don't know what their
you know what the policies are what
their plans are but i'd love to i got
like 50 emails
of people recommending them to me i i
emailed them
uh and i hit them up on twitter so uh
yeah
reply back guys softshellcrab says been
a
been a new fan for the last uh last few
months going to become a member on your
site next paycheck
what to ask y'all do y'all play
commander as magic the gathering format
yeah it's the only thing we play
basically we played some draft a couple
weeks ago that was really fun
adam adam has a cube that he built with
like all these we were playing the
unglued set
and the unhinged and all those weird
like fun hold a card above the table
type fun stuff there's one where it's
like you have to make a creature with
your hand standing on the table and if
you take your hand off the creature dies
oh yeah i remember that silly silly
silly
but uh that aren't familiar majestica oh
yeah that's a majestically
funny there was like you have to whisper
a word and then if they do it it
causes a creature essentially i'll just
you know layman's terms becomes inactive
so i chose betsam majestica but mostly
we play commander yeah i
don't want no idea what you guys are
saying we'll get you a deck yeah
it's a it's a card game okay it's only
for smart people you know so i i
like math yeah very smart people uh the
way to describe it to people is chess
and poker combined i got a question for
you luke if there were five colors of
magic for you to choose from he's not
gonna
and those colors were black white no you
can't red you can't ask him
green or blue no what color would you
pick no you can't ask him this he
doesn't understand
because each of the colors represents a
characteristic or emotion he doesn't
understand well
use your imagination of those five
colors what you feel
most akin to right now or forever just
in general
he doesn't know a personality test so in
magic the gathering it's a card game
there are five colors and each each
color represents a what they call a
color identity
the the color black represents swamps
and it's ambition meaning
you would sacrifice you cut off your own
arm to defeat your opponent like things
like that
then you have green which represents
growth so it's creatures and elves and
forests
you have blue which represents control
so it's illusions and manipulation
you have if he doesn't know anything
about red is fire and destruction
aggression and and and passion and chaos
and white is benevolence and healing
and you know okay
so what how where would you alive i
don't know i
don't want to play these games i like
stuff like the ufc yeah and then people
fighting and all
that luke would be ready
tim's more of a red midge
red and blue blue you like red red i
like blue a lot chaos and control that's
my
that's my favorite you fit well with red
it's fits your personality a lot
sounds like all right let's read some
more some people are i'm not going to
read this but some people are asking uh
where stephen crowder is
oh yeah i don't know vacation yeah he's
gone i don't know he must be
he's uh in a secret underground he's
loving that we're talking about him
right now
oh he's bike chilling man he's probably
fishing having a good time
going to the range maybe he told himself
if trump doesn't win he's taking some
time off
stephen crowder probably enjoying a nice
bowl of clam chowder down at the you
know
brewery or something hopefully yeah my
mind minding his own business
dark party says i followed luke shirt
boy for 18 hours then
then he started trashing on trump well
of course yeah that's what i've been
doing my entire
life yeah i've been i've been trashing
on all the presidents from
whenever i could yeah i will say i think
it's worth to continue to follow luke
because he'll give you
non-partisan advice i don't like anyone
especially when they're politicians
yeah well but you got to understand too
like if somebody is like biden is the
best trump is
the worst you probably will need a voice
like luke is going to be like let me
tell you why they're all bad
you know because at least you know
you're not getting a tribalist to take
down of trump you're getting someone's
critique who doesn't like any of them
i'm not for everyone but thanks for
giving me a try
thank you crazy bear says tim poole
doesn't always sell blackface merch but
when he does it's hilarious
that was it was when i saw it i was just
like oh
geez i had to laugh oh no no it's not
quite blackface
well the white fists yeah they're so
crazy
it was on purpose but i'm not taking
heat for that that's on teespring disney
do you know
i respect them for looking into it they
apologized and they and i think it was
probably
in my opinion a rogue employee it was a
third party company i'm sorry not an
employee of them they said it was a
third party
so we'll see what they end up finding
out you know maybe
maybe they're all laughing behind the
scenes they did on purpose but i don't
think that's the case
let's see track media only says news
media gets away with it in part because
libel laws have been broken or totally
bypassed
people yell first amendment not taking
into account libel laws have existed
before and after its creation
that's right simple caleb says oregon
governor kate brown cleared d1 schools
to play sports
smaller naia schools in the same area
are not
rules for the but not for the elite
schools that probably benefit
uh benefit kate brown's interests that's
right
daddy t says here's to bernie showing up
showing up to a buttoned down event
wearing oven mitts
i thought the mittens were nice and they
were funny and then i was sad to learn
they were destroyed by over taxation so
well there you go nuclear winter game
gamer says i hail from saskatchewan
canada and sentiment of western
separation grows more and more the
longer pm aladdin sits in office
wecks it sorry about shirt
listen i don't care about the shirt in
the sense that if people got it and they
have it fine
just so long as i've made myself clear
that that was not on us
if anyone wants to get mad about that
shirt you take it up with teespring if
some people got it and they're happy
with it don't put that on me because i'm
not the one who made it
you know what i mean i'm sure there's
people who got it are laughing and they
like it because it's a misprint and it's
unique
and i'm sure there are probably a lot of
racist people who are trying to get one
don't look at me i didn't make
it so teespring that's on you you
scratch out the tim cass and put
t-spring on it
gareth green says i realized the vietnam
war was a waste of resources and lives
but the world would be a better place if
south vietnam had been saved
which we could have if we had played it
to win iraq was a mistake no question
look i'll tell you i'm i'm very grateful
about the us involvement in korea
what can i say i don't like military
intervention but my it has a lot to do
with my family and they were fleeing
and and what happened to my family later
on and what it means for the people of
south korea to be free and be able to
thrive and have some of the best
technology companies in the on the
planet and north korea
is sad and if the u.s wasn't involved
it would all of korea would be a
communist wasteland
helmsway says tim i am the man wearing
the shirt you showed earlier
the look on my girlfriend's face when i
took it out of the package and put it on
was priceless
teespring changed my design
well thank you guys for buying this
shirt and letting me know what happened
when it did i think
i think you guys got the very first one
so
um for everybody else expect probably
yours to come soon and uh well now
there's gonna be like a thousand of them
we'll see mr hunt first name mike says
antifa literally the most ignorant fools
on the planet
yeah braden says did you hear about
biden rolling an armored convoy into
syria i did
it was reported by it was it is it itv
it was a publication from i believe
jordan wasn't it well there was syrian
state television reported it
but then there was also i think it was
itv reported it yeah and then several
others were reporting it some tried
downplaying it saying
the u.s moves convoys all the time
others are saying biden took
wasted no time ramping up the military
presence in syria well others are saying
it's reinforcement to the already very
small number of troops in the northeast
and russia it looks like also matched it
with their own reinforcements and
over 300 soldiers that they just sent to
that same region he's escalating
our troop force in syria well we're
going to find out uh
we can't independently verify that for
now okay it looks
curious curious mishap says
german starved death when the berlin
wall was in place america lied about
sending supplies
that's what my german grandmother
remembered while we watched a
documentary on it
never trust the media or was it that
the government of east germany lied to
your grandmother
it's really hard to know who was being
honest you might believe your
grandmother and i respect that
but was your grandmother being
manipulated and lied to by communists
communists are not known for having food
so so just a heads up
you know uh you know my family had to go
through it too in poland
a lot of them ended up hungry and a lot
of them didn't have the basic
necessities that we take advantage of
right now daniel maxwell says reads
luke's shirt
so who wishes that george orwell had not
been so accurate with his predictions
for the future
i mean i like it boy did i call it or
what i think he's like
yeah fantastic writer if you guys
haven't read 1984 in animals well he's a
fascinating person his real name was
eric blair he
literally was involved in wars he was a
mi5 agent
his story is is just absolutely profound
to say the least animal farm also
another great book
that a lot of people don't uh you know
attribute to him
but there's so many important pieces of
literature that he puts together that
really are worth
reading and a lot of the public school
systems are pushing them out
i remember being introduced to them in
the new york city public school system
and i remember being fascinated by both
of those books and they had a tremendous
impact on me i found that
animal farm was like a story about
the rise of totalitarianism and then
1984 was a story
about a system that was already
totalitarian so it's almost like they
were a sequel
a sequel yeah yeah yeah bob samar
some archic some artistic says ian
you're the effing man that is all
what up homie matthias says can you
please talk about the book called the
creature of jekyll island by g edward
griffin
i think everyone in the world should
read this book i have it downstairs
it's that's about the right book we
should have g edward griffin on he is an
amazing
smart individual that that interviewed
the kgb
agent that just like talked to him on
twitter maybe
but he just he doesn't just talk about
uh you know the federal reserve he talks
about a lot of stuff that
the cia he knows a lot about a lot cia
food
medicine all this other stuff that uh
pretty much pretty eye opening
g edward shinobi kenobi says tim won't
say certain things to prevent from
getting banned on youtube but wanted
trump to bargain assange etc
when corrupt r's and d's held conviction
over his head and destruction of
he and his family's lives yeah there is
a balancing act
donald trump was on his way out and
there's a difference between
i guess the comfort of the president as
he's losing all of his you know about to
lose all of the power he has and
and dropping one last bomb and me
sitting here thinking
if we can talk about 95 of things that
are extremely important the mainstream
media won't cover and we can call them
out
and that means there are five percent of
things i'll have to put on my own
website i think that makes sense
if there if i was told by youtube you
will be banned effective tomorrow
i would make the craziest video you've
ever seen and i would just i'd be like
here's what we're gonna do
what we're doing now is yeah there's
some things i can't say on youtube
and it's only a couple things it's like
a name and i mean it's really the only
thing i really have to worry about
saying some guy's name and swearing and
stuff
but we can talk about all that clean and
safe at timcast.com
so that's the plan you got to be smart
it's about playing 4d chess man
i'm not just gonna like i don't
understand why they're people who are
like tim why don't you say something and
get banned instantly so you can't work
or talk to talk about anything anymore
that makes no sense so what we're doing
is
what we've accomplished on youtube the
resources we've acquired
we're making a proprietary website that
can't be banned for the most part
and finding ways to make sure we can
always get you the real news and
accurate information
while leveraging the resources we have
just be honest we got to choose our
battles
some battles we're just going to be
obliterated and totally destroyed and
never be able to fight again if we
decide to fight those battles
and just like you did i started doing
the same thing on we are change.org i
have a very similar system
i have certain videos that that i know
would get automatically banned that i
just put on there and people could see
them
but there's other creators who got
banned that are criticizing me
uh right now and i understand where
they're coming from
but at the same time when you see people
who got nuked
their reach is tremendously limited
and we have to you know do things in a
way where we
reach as many people as we can with so
many important things and
and you you make that compromise and we
have to be honest and i want to stress
this too
do you think that donald trump caving to
the deep state is going to
is gonna save him of course of course
it's not they're
they're they're coming for this guy dude
the the the state ag's are coming for
him he negotiated
nothing in fact in my opinion if assange
did get out and assange could work to
expose what was being done
to him and his family he'd be better off
instead i wouldn't be surprised if they
convict the guy
and then they take away everything from
him and they say you had your chance and
you blew it
why it's it's like it reminds me of any
superhero movie where the villain is
like give me this and i'll let you go
it's like why should i trust the villain
yeah you know
gi joe that was always cobra commander
hanging out and they're gonna
help me and then duke's like helps him
out when he pushes him off the ledge
is that really that really happened yeah
it's cobra commander you can't trust
cobra commander
exactly so look i i admit it's tough and
there's probably a lot of things i don't
know about what happened with trump
maybe what they threatened him with was
something worse than i could possibly
imagine so i'll respect that and i'll
respect what you were saying for sure
i can i can't pretend to be perfect
gareth green says i humbly submit that
the corruption of the american medical
industry is because of government
intervention therein
and a real free market would make those
problems evaporate
perhaps gabriel montiel says i had my
wisdom teeth taken out in colombia for
25 bucks each and they did an amazing
job nice
wow yeah but did you get them pulled or
surgically removed you know what they do
in mexico
i think you were telling me this they
use your own blood yeah
to heal your the wound in your mouth
after the surgery they did that to me
yeah and uh they don't do that here i
think they might some places
yep i still have giant gaping holes
where they used to be i had them
surgically removed so so
when they so i got a wisdom tooth put in
that they had to like you know
basically cutting up your mouth yeah
they cut a hole and then dig it out and
then
what they do in mexico is they take your
own blood to help build up the area and
it heals fascination prp
that's erp platelet-rich plasma they'll
also use that to inject into wounds like
knees and things like that for rhymes
people fast
amazing so when i had dental work done
they were like oh we're just going to
take your blood i'm like okay give me
the
myers-briggs cocktail give me some
vitamin c and give me some other stuff
and there's
a break uh i think there's a specific
like
immune system boosting cocktail that
they have a whole bunch of vitamins
isn't myers briggs like
entjs personality tests i i'm probably
butchering it
and probably had another fraudulent slip
you said on the other on the bonus
segment you said lower the decimals
same thing you know what i'm trying to
say you're just trying to be elitist
okay i'm trying to be elitist you know
what i'm braggs
brags is the company that uh puts out
all that health food and the
myers-briggs is a personality test
well i think it sounds very similar this
is
some we're i'm being blackmailed here
jandyn patterson says tim a mecca says
hi
i bet this chant chat won't be read if
you do read it i will send another super
chat and become a member of the
timcast.com site
found this channel like seven or eight
months ago and couldn't believe that
and then there's a there's one more let
me see there's another one
it's always hard because if the numbers
are different it's hard to uh there we
go
a youtube dude like mr milky toast and
button masher lydia and a few other plus
t-shirt luke and ian wannabe
men vitality spinner and there's one
more there's one more
let me try let me try and find the next
one speaking of the male vitality i had
some in my coffee earlier oh nice
oh it's hard to find three oh no
third time's a charm come on we can do
this
i'm i'm looking for it be a nice feature
if you could link oh youtube just jumped
on me
oh no it's the mayor's cocktail mayors
like meyers or mayors m-y-e-r-s
oh okay okay myers that's like vitamin b
vitamin c
and a whole bunch of other stuff in
there that sounds good
i'm trying to find the third the third
and last puzzle
no you can do it no i can't find it you
can do anything
calcium a whole bunch of stuff that
sounds great yeah it's like a
like a multivitamin yeah but uh
intravenously oh very cool oh
they give it for your body to heal after
yesterday so when they were doing the
when they were taking out my blood to do
the prp uh i was like just give me some
extra vitamins and stuff and they did it
and i think they've made that also
illegal in the united states and in some
states as well so
all right well i'll have to find the
super chat eventually but we have too
many but let's read some more
jose pia pereira says i just read an
article about how apple spent 90
thousand dollars for lobbyists to
educate policymakers
regarding bill to stop uyghur slave
labor from daily caller
wow that's creepy stuff i don't like it
ricky bobby says hey tim i watched an
hour-long podcast with
raul paul from real vision investments
it isn't that goods are inflating it's
the fact that our wages are
our deflating gives the appearance of
inflation but it's not interesting stuff
really interesting interesting did you
guys uh who was it you i think you said
that joe biden is
joe bob jr no no yeah but i don't think
it's bob it's robinette so it's robin i
think
joe robin i think calling him bob might
be wrong the short for rob could be bob
yeah it is could be joe bob but joe bob
jr yeah
joe rob i don't know what's short for
robinette if it's bob i would say not
robin
yeah bob's good enough uncle president
bobby some other people are also
mentioning bunker branding so we'll
definitely check them out
matthew gregory says second attempt at
super chat my brother was hurt and
attempted robbery on him
he owes 50k in hospital fees america
insurance can suck
yes that is true let's see uh
lady symfia says hey tim have you heard
of vulcan west virginia
they had to ask the ussr to build a
bridge for them because the us
government would not
wow really that's amazing curtis sees a
politician should never be paid a salary
more than the median income of their
constituents
san francisco median income is 53 000
if the government is for and by uh for
by and of the people they should be paid
accordingly i like that yeah
the challenge is you know like andrew
yang said we should actually pay
politicians a ridiculous amount to
disincentivize disloyalty
because if the lobbyists are like you're
not making any money trust me we'll make
you rich
if they're rich from their public
service job they're going to be like nah
you're going to jeopardize the
the rich life i already have i don't
know it could go either way because some
people are going to be like i'll take
more money i don't care most of them are
psychopaths that have
unlimited uh hunger for uh power and
money so
i don't know if that would work yep yeah
yeah they just want more yep
rob ingram says dude here in pa the
liquor control board has a monopoly that
makes it so financially hard on
restaurants and bars
let's deregulate abolish the pl liquor
control
pa liquor control board there you go
amen
good call dis says check out reddit
simulator it's reddit with all bots
talking to each other and it's very
creepy
i've seen that it's amazing yeah gareth
green says parlor is not gone they found
a new web host epic
yeah but they're only doing i think like
a splash page for now
tanner barnes says the donald win got
taken down that's not true it changed to
patriots.win because
donald trump isn't president anymore so
like what do you do
so i guess they just rebranded for a
variety of reasons and they're all still
basically doing the same thing
that was obviously calming too because i
mean
there's a community here that believes
in something they're not going to just
go away
so they they made it work it is what it
is i do i do think what they're doing
with the wind community is a good thing
because it's effectively creating a
decentralized reddit
and so a lot of these ban communities
are showing up i don't agree with some
of these and i think a lot of some of
these you know communities have crazy
people in them but people have a right
to free speech to be protected
harold cole says you really you should
really check out bunker branding for
t-shirt printing and sales we will
that's awesome rj lewer says did you see
the new joe rogan with tulsi
she was basically exposing how corrupt
and treasonous the dems are and joe
would just gloss over it
tulsi you should come on this show we
won't we won't gloss over it and i'm a
big fan
and uh i'll leave it there but uh
definitely would love to have tulsi on
uh still a big fan supported her
throughout her her campaign
and i really believed in what she was
what she was doing and i really respect
the military service
i had a night where i was in my
apartment
thinking about tulsi and supporting her
and i just started crying
so that's how into it i was she's great
she's amazing yeah she's super cool
dude's so legit yeah uh brandon tom says
you say what uh what happened to turn
the other cheek
and then fault republicans for doing
nothing what is the appropriate middle
ground if any
well when we're talking about turning
into the cheek i think we're referencing
violence and stuff
you know like not engaging in the same
tit for tat
that's not resulting in anything
impeaching donald trump wasn't a
solution anything it was chaos
the problem with republicans is they're
not advocating for republicans or even
americans
republicans aren't coming out there and
being like we're gonna propose a bill
that will
rescind these laws curtailing people's
gun rights like think about this
we've had uh a bunch of bans like are
republicans on board the bump stock ban
like what do you think about that uh
most of the republicans
know it's it's an extremely big
overreach of power that criminalized
millions of americans and made them
felons overnight
previously republicans support it uh
donald trump supported it and he pushed
it
through and it's absolutely insane
because previous gun restrictive
measures were
measures that would grandfather people
in that wouldn't automatically turn
people into felonies but if you had this
thing
overnight felony jail possession
uh for for something that people were
were buying knowingly so it was a huge
step forward in in gun uh in anti-gun
legislation that really should have been
pushed back immediately
we got a question for luke dice goblin
says luke question for you if we have no
taxes how do the men and women who
choose to serve get paid for their
service
uh there's many other you know you
plunder uh you you uh
you say we give you carte blanche to
raid that country whatever you get is
yours heck yeah
well no obviously not you would have uh
you know other incentives that you could
do and and also other collectives that
you could uh you know
you know reach and and and agree upon
right that's so vague
we got wait do you think we should
repeal all taxes i
i don't like taxes uh i don't like taxes
like i think i think
you know a lot of people usually like to
nitpick these larger and cap ideas
when of course a lot of them are just
like
northern stars they're they're they're
you know navigations of where we should
be headed towards because obviously the
taxes are way too high
so to take everything literal is a
little bit disingenuous
but to say that it's a good starting
point to aim for is good
do i have all the answers and solutions
when we get there i don't so you think
we need less taxes
100 i think that i don't like that i
don't know where my taxes go
yeah you can look that up black and
budget there's a thing called a black
budget
the problem is the size and scale of
things make it impossible for a regular
person to actually be able to do this
like you can actually look up the
budgets and the expenditures and stuff
but you got to be an expert to
understand it and do the math yeah it's
not easy
and so it's the scale of things that are
making it very difficult to track what's
going on and
well luke mentions the federal reserve
missing money and stuff like that yeah
the pentagon
came up with like 1.3 trillion they lost
when the government has enough money to
give to foreign countries
that's when you know they have too much
money when the pentagon loses
a trillion dollars i i should i really
want that i was looking for that story
earlier i couldn't find
it they moved around through 35 trillion
dollars in budgeting a couple years ago
the pentagon are you guys
i don't know if it was not that much but
uh even before 9 11 there was trillions
of dollars missing and no one could
account for them
like the day before it was like
september 10th the pentagon misplaced
1.3 trillion dollars there's donald
rumsfeld about that
and uh well we got a super chat here for
for ian
uncultured barbarian says wrong night
but ian's right trump definitely corrupt
1997 rothschilds bailed him out because
taj mahal bankrupted him
they own half of that casino in several
of his properties former commerce
secretary wilbur ross is source
interesting i was thinking about the
nepotism conversation and then today i
was like
i think kind of bothers me is that he
surrounded himself with yes men
and including his daughter and his
daughters that's not true they were just
like daddy
people she cried she got him to go to
war over crying
and leaking everything dude he hired a
bunch of bad people who didn't help him
and didn't work for him you want to hire
people that will
that will confront you and push back on
your ideas but instead the people he
hired were secretly leaking things
behind his back
yeah they were yes man and then they
betrayed him he was probably the most
leaked on no pun intended president of
the united
states like he if people push back on
him he would fire him so they would all
be like yes yes yes and then they'd leak
the incense well we got a very important
chris lamson says where can i get a
print of the art behind luke
this art is from george alex opolis also
known as g
prime85 on social media and i believe he
sells prince and it's some of the best
art ever
in fact behind luke is joe biden eating
uh okay boomer girl
and behind uh ian there's two there's
one with joe
rogan and then there's one on the ground
of joe biden also eating a little girl
there we go
he released a really good one today with
uh joe biden playing with toy soldiers
and throwing them back
in and they ended up in parking lots
right right
grew all says yo tim biden just sent
more troops into syria and ascending
more to iraq and israel just killed four
people biden america
yeah josh says could you add a number of
retweets
like and or mentions when you see the
sycophantic tweets
syncophantic would be nice to know when
those tweets are just yelling fire in a
theater but very limited views may help
turn down the temperature
yeah there was somebody claiming like a
bunch of the leftists are trying to get
fox news banned
saying that fox news is essentially
yelling fire in a crowded theater so
it's illegal obviously and it's like
people don't realize you're legally
allowed to heal fire in a crowded
theater
but the theater will throw you out i
mean if they want to they don't have to
you're allowed to say it is it it is
legal
it is illegal to go tell people that
something is about to happen if it's not
yes it is it is a myth even don lemon
recently like a week or two ago
chris i think it was like i think it was
chris cuomo who said
you can't yell fire in a credit theater
and don goes no no that's not true
that's not true
you can't say that that's a myth and
cuomo is like it is true it is true
it's like cuomo you're like he was a
lawyer wasn't he there's no idea what
he's talking about getting closer
it's a lawyer if i'm in a movie theater
i see someone scream fire
in front of me i'm just going to take a
look he doesn't say anything but he says
it again i'm going to kick his chair
all right so it's like problem solved
yeah christian larson says dictator
biden has turned all comments on the
white house youtube channel
off but it was uh the will of the people
that voted him in
i don't think he's allowed to do that i
think you could file a suit right now
like anybody could did donald trump have
his comments on they were in the white
house
but when he blocked people they argued
that that's those posts were
forums and the government has no right
to shut them down so biden the white
house team doing this
i think it's unconstitutional it's
different than banning individuals just
shutting the forum off yeah i mean
they're scared of people that's a good
point
well yeah because trump didn't shut the
forum down he just removed certain
people
shutting the form down might be okay all
right let's see
akira express trucker says republicans
are not pro-2a
they are pro-2a when it's politically
convenient but are the party that passes
the legislation to control access
yep yep all right let's see let's just
do we'll do one more here big toe says
we'll do a couple more turn on him uh
turn to him the other cheek is not about
violence it's about
insult a slap in the face nuke the ice
caps
says not a fan of all the free money
it's very hard to explain to desperate
people that free comes with a lot of
debt and consequences
i try to explain this i've had people
say yeah but they're gonna give me money
idiocracy is now a documentary ladies
and gentlemen thank you so much for
hanging out thanks for the super chats
make sure to
go to timcast.com because we do have one
more segment coming up for members only
yes and um a little spicy maybe we'll
see how things play out but
we're gonna we're gonna be ramping up
the amount of content we produce for
members and i
mean it i mean like i'm talking maybe
hours worth of content every day at some
point because we're gonna have fun
videos we're gonna have vlog videos
some of the bonus segments we've done
have already been 20 minutes so we're
going to try and just do as much as
possible to really make it worth your
membership
and we're also going to be eventually
producing free content
that will just appear on the website too
so probably opinion pieces some articles
maybe photos
and then the real premium stuff will be
members only go to timcast.com
we are trying to get to a point where if
we get enough members then we will no
longer
have anything to worry about about
censorship now look
if youtube bans us a lot of people will
probably never see our stuff again
that's a fact
but if we just have a core user base
then that's still good enough for us to
keep working then i'll accept that and
that means if you guys really do like
what we do and want to make sure you're
getting it
timcast.com and also hopefully if this
time
you buy your exclusive i am a gorilla
t-shirt it won't be
a blackface version so i hope teespring
is taking care of that
they said they are and you know my
respect for them getting quickly on this
and trying to get the problem solved
but tapeguys.com shop and you can follow
me on twitter instagram
and mines at tim cast and my other
youtube channels are youtube.com
timcast and youtube.comcastnews and
i believe luke is a t-shirt vendor
they're trying to take down my shirts
but they can't
take me down i'm doing everything in my
power
literally as i said i'm a horrible
drawer if i have to draw them
i will and i will personally send them
out to you the website is
thebestpoliticalshirts.com keep an eye
out for that because
no matter who's going to do something
i'm always going to find a way to get
you
the shirts that you want and sign up on
my email list on we are change.org on
the top right hand corner it makes
people invincible i have a direct
contact
to talk to you one-on-one i have a lot
of interesting things to say so
check it out and thank you so much for
doing so
i think they're throwing it to me it
keeps happening that's right um it's
subtle though because they don't say my
name
hey thanks guys i'm ian crossland as you
may or may not know
you can follow me in crossover online i
really want to thank uh all the new
people that have started following me
online my youtube channel is over ten
thousand subscribers
oh yeah it just keeps going up excellent
1000 a month i don't know it's getting
bigger faster
uh twitch twitter facebook which i don't
take new friends on but you can follow
me there um mine's
instagram and we're gonna be gaming
later tonight on twitch.tv slash ian
crossland i'll be gaming with adam
kriegler we're going to play some red
dead
redemption 2. see what kind of chaos we
can
we can engender is that the right word
cause cause yeah cause that's the word i
was looking for gender works yeah
so follow me and catch me at twitch.tv
slash ian crossland tonight
yeah and then me i'm sour patch lids on
twitter
uh and uh i'm real sour patch lids on
let me see if i can get it right
instagram and
gab yes okay i got it i got my own
socials all right and then i i really
appreciate everyone signing up on
timcast.com
if you have problems email members at
timcast.com and look at you straightened
out just because i have
a special announcement oh gosh tim's
whispering we've got footage
of luke wrkowski getting raided by alex
jones play it
that sounds inappropriate can i use the
restroom yeah it's gonna be up on
timcast.com for members only along with
the lost episode you should do a picture
just a screenshot from the video of luke
getting woken up yes
with a link to the website so people can
and we'll post it and so if you want to
watch alex jones break into luke's
trailer and wake him up
and love him say inappropriate things i
love it so we'll have that as well
and um yeah we've got a lot of stuff to
come the lost episode is the one that
got pulled from youtube
oh yeah and so it does exist it is on
bit shoot you can watch it it exists but
for a lot of people who missed it
it'll be up um it will be up on the site
for members only
but again it is if you can find it on
bit shoot by looking at the tim cast irl
channel because we archive all our stuff
there as well so it is free
but we'll put it up in the member
section so ladies and gentlemen
make sure you check it out because
before that show starts we will have the
exclusive
footage of of alex and it'll be fun and
uh thanks for hanging out
we'll see you over at timcast.com other
than that you know i'm going to take
weekends off probably from now on
so i'll see you on monday thanks
everybody
you